how's it going everybody we are once
again at uh the capitol basically we got
a lot of news to talk about but we're
going straight to the source to figure
out what's going on over this past week
we got a lot of information about
January 6 and I think some of the most
interesting and most important
Revelations maybe even in in uh Our
Generation when it comes to government
malfeasance and politics is that FBI
agents were apparently trying to or may
have actually deleted evidence in a
January 6 or multiple January 6 cases
this information comes out apparently
implicating that some feds were actually
involved in trying to obfuscate their
involvement by requesting the removal of
their name from from evidence
this is freaky stuff so we're gonna talk
about that we got a bunch of other
stories that may or may not come up I
saw a viral tweet where on The View Jane
Fonda alludes to murdering people who
are pro-life in a rather shocking
statement and then immediately everyone
starts laughing saying oh it's a joke
it's a joke and then she gives this look
like
mm-hmm like yeah I don't know if they're
joking and that's kind of freaky I don't
want to be hyperbolic but considering
everything we've seen it's been getting
pretty CR pretty crazy so we're gonna
have an awesome show we have a bunch of
guests coming in we're literally sitting
in Matt Gates's office before we get
started however head over to timcast.com
become a member to support our work
because that is the bulk of how we run
this company when you guys suddenly
become members you are basically making
sure we can do these shows we can set
these shows up on the road very
difficult uh task and expensive but uh
if you believe in us and we believe in
you then support our work at timcast.com
smash that like button subscribe to this
Channel and share the show right now
because we're gonna have some breaking
news tonight joining us tonight first is
rep Matt Gates welcome to Capitol Hill
we're in the Rayburn office building and
I'm loving Tim cast on the road because
having to go out into the survival
situation that is the track to your new
your usual headquarters uh is
treacherous but this is this is great
man we've enjoyed having your team here
in the office and I got I got an opening
take because having come on your show a
couple times now like they're the people
who see me in the news so I gotta I
gotta pause you uh we're a little low on
volume surge yep
all right well let's just roll with it
because it is what it is sorry continue
no problem the benefits of a live show
they're people who see me in the news
and they'll come and say oh you know we
saw you on Fox or Sally on CNN or
whatever but the people who have come up
to me to say they see me on Tim cast
it's like we're having a secret
handshake there is a there is an
intimacy to it there's a like I know we
have a connection because I was watching
you on Tim cast so cool know that
there's a community there's a sense of
community out there that goes beyond
normal media that frankly you probably
couldn't develop on traditional media
these days and I think one of The
Cutting Edge Advantage is of a platform
like this is that people when they tune
in when they're a part of the discussion
when they feel like they're at the head
of the table with us then
we've done something real so I think we
lost sound completely
bike's peaking yeah it's audios audio's
gone totally gone
no no it's totally gone bro can you hear
me live what's happening
so we had a uh
we have we brought a custom soundboard
and everything we got it set up
everything was working just fine and
then like a half an hour out for some
reason we have no idea why I just
stopped oh they can hear me we're good
but it's it's uh okay cool people are
saying it's distorted and low but low
sounds better than the view
the actual through this atem
yeah well I can I can see the mixer
picking it up and there's like nothing
there it's it's like minus 50 DB
tell us in the chat oh I like the wide
shot it's it's pretty bad
no idea maybe we should have just used
your setup
I got a rig yeah our customer doesn't
see me work it sounds like the
distortion's cranked up like it's an
electric guitar like I don't know if
it's just the amount of time we spend
talking or if it's like I don't know
maybe it's just real people make real
Community but yeah I like that Vibe it
is and the the cross section of people
like uh like we talked last time White
Collar Blue Collar no collar no shoes
yeah no collar no colors just fine all
the above you're from Florida yeah oh I
mean the jean shorts and Crocs is
basically the Florida man uniform before
we get too deep into this let me just
introduce myself I'm Ian cross and if
you don't know me now you do what's
happening uh and also we have Phil
abanti to my right how you doing uh
philabonte lead singer of All That
Remains anti-communist
counter-revolutionary and we're going to
have uh rep Dan bishop and I believe
Steve Bannon joining us later tonight
that's right
what a All-Star panel man we got Bishop
we got Bannon it's gonna be great well
let's uh let's talk about the first
thing there's a lot of news I mean the
the Silicon Valley Bank stuff is pretty
crazy but I think uh I want to talk to
you about what's going on with January 6
because I think it was uh a year ago you
mentioned Federal involvement in uh I'll
just put it simply in some capacity I
think you were a bit more direct but now
we have this story where apparently they
tried I think they may have actually
literally destroyed evidence there's
Communications where they said I was
instructed to destroy 338 pieces of
evidence and in one communication even
said remove my remove the agent's name
from this from this document as present
at one of these incidents that to me
sounds like they're trying to destroy or
may have literally destroyed evidence of
their involvement as it pertains to the
seditious conspiracy charges uh I've
been involved in taking the transcribed
interviews of several FBI whistleblowers
from around the country and a
substantial amount of the testimony that
they've given us deals with with the
treatment of people who were unfairly
targeted as domestic extremists or
somehow associated with January 6th when
in fact in a great number of these cases
there was no predicate criminal act to
even investigate no evidence that people
had committed crimes so I normally
wouldn't go into evidence in the middle
of an of an ongoing investigation but
something interesting happened as these
FBI whistleblowers came in the Democrats
would release out of context portions of
their Depots and then would do
opposition research on the
whistleblowers and blast that out in
reports to try to discredit the work
before we could even even begin it and
since they've done that we feel like we
need to vindicate the stories of these
people who've come forward because think
about the deterrent effect if every time
a whistleblower comes forward to share
evidence of FBI misconduct that their
family gets smeared their spouse gets
fired their targeted their financial
situation degrades they can't get jobs
and so they're trying to discourage the
truth from coming out and that's why
recently at CPAC I called to remove the
Democrats from the transcribed
interviews if they're if their
involvement in the investigation is
going to be to harm the investigation
they shouldn't even be included and if
you look at what happened during the
January 6th investigation it wasn't like
anybody who had an opposing view was in
the room the Republicans they counted
were Adam kinzinger and Liz Cheney and
so I think that that's an initial step
but it wouldn't surprise me we saw an
FBI lawyer change evidence before a
secret court and that guy had pled
guilty to a crime and now has his law
license back can you believe that I mean
think about the message that sends so
the FBI Patriots who stepped forward and
say you know what
I'm being asked to do weird and possibly
unlawful things to people who you're
claiming are some sort of
insurrectionist because of January 6th
and we
put those folks on no-fly lists we ruin
their lives and then at the same time
someone who literally admitted to
changing evidence
to try to implicate someone close to
Trump to get surveillance on the Trump
campaign that guy can practice law in DC
this week you see uh Elon Musk just
tweeted free uh effectively saying free
Jacob chansley they posted the video of
him being escorted through the building
I'm wondering what are your thoughts on
that the video release from Tucker
Carlson I don't know everything that
that guy did but what I saw there was a
very confusing situation that really is
indicative of like the fog of War where
people don't really know what's going on
the sense of a of a rules-based order
kind of changes I think there were a lot
of people
and and again I don't know everything
chance leader I don't know if there's
gonna gonna be a different feature to
his involvement that day but that
conduct
did not appear to be
criminal or violent or worthy of the
type of extended prison even if it's a
technical violation of federal criminal
law Prosecuting that putting some
someone in prison Just For Those
portions well we saw on Tucker seemed
itself not justifiable Elon Musk tweeted
a video of him standing outside with a
with a bullhorn saying everyone leave go
home Trump says go home he doesn't want
you here and they're yelling at him no
no we're coming so not only do you have
this guy being escorted through the
building it appears and the cops even
try to open the doors for him at one
point bring them to an open door for the
Senate chamber he's actually on video
telling people to leave well here's the
problem
in his plea deal he has signed away all
his rights of appeal so he doesn't even
have the ability to open the courthouse
gates to be able to have a resolution of
those questions any honorable and
reasonable prosecutor would make their
own motion
and would make it along with the defense
if necessary to set aside that plea deal
and to be able to evaluate the extent of
criminal Acuity that is what a moral
prosecutor would do they would not be
drug into court by the defense lawyer
they would actually go and make the
motion themselves
uh what I have seen come out of the doj
and the Washington field office of the
FBI is that this place is the geography
of rot there is not political capture of
the FBI in every corner of this country
it is New York it is Washington D.C
principally and that's why what Nancy
Pelosi did authorizing the funding of a
new FBI headquarters in the greater
Washington area larger than the Pentagon
is something that could should concern
you more than re-changing the you know
carpets at the J Edgar Hoover building
frankly I think a lot of these folks
deserve to sit at the rat infested Jay
Edgar Hoover building as long as
necessary but we certainly shouldn't be
building the FBI
a pentagon-sized facility to insource to
the most corrupt geography in the world
more of the work that actually would be
legitimate to protect the American
people that a lot of good folks are
doing where is this building is first
I've heard of it oh it's in well it's
authorized and funded in the big Omnibus
legislation that Nancy Pelosi the 1.7
trillion dollars in spending that we
talked about last time uh we were on the
show part of that was this massive
facility for the FBI and it's going to
be out in Northern Virginia but right
here within the northern Virginia
Maryland DC swamp do they tell you what
it's going to look like is it going to
be a fortress I don't care if it looks
like you know the uh Taj Mahal I don't I
don't want to see that many billets here
I don't I think that people you know we
we saw Inspector General reports of
people in the media taking these FBI
agents out for tickets at sporting
events concerts fancy meals in exchange
for information and that's just a way to
smear people
I heard someone talking about the FBI
and they had mentioned that the role of
the FBI had gone from and someone at one
of the hearings that the FBI's rule had
gone from being a law enforcement agency
to being an intelligence agency
so that was the post-9 11 thing that's a
very astute observation because
pre-911 the job of the FBI was to
investigate these crimes that had
occurred that had a multi-state feature
to them that one jurisdiction couldn't
handle with a higher degree of scale on
technology and Innovation to be able to
solve those crimes and to bring
prosecutions
after 9 11 Bush goes to Comey and
basically says it's not enough to
investigate crimes and bring
prosecutions we have to go and be
predictive we have to go and be an
intelligence organization to stop things
from happening in the future and and
that resulted in a culture shift that a
lot of the old-timers that kind of you
know Joe Friday types resented yeah
how do we so what do you do so how do
you get the because the whole culture
there is of if it's of an intelligence
gathering agency that means that the the
target is the American people it's the
only target the FBI could have so then
how do you change the culture I mean
personally I'm for tearing the whole
goddamn thing apart but like what do you
do you know what do you do
to begin the process of of trying to
change the mindset of the FBI at the top
level because it can't it's not going to
happen if it's because you're talking
about field offices it's not going to
happen just at field offices it has to
be you know the people that are working
at the at the at the Jagger Hooper
building you know so what do you do I
think decentralizing the human resources
would have a forcing function of
decentralizing some of the power and
frankly where they have authorities
where they've used them time and again
to Institute political enforcement we
need to curtail those authorities the
foreign intelligence surveillance act
702 Authority has caught a number of
Americans in a Dragnet that
doesn't end run around our Constitution
and so that is an authority that I think
needs to be curtailed
um you know they uh just that they have
a foreign influence task force and what
I've observed is that this foreign
influence task force operated for the
bidens a lot like they said the plumbers
operated for Richard Nixon you know
they'd go remember they would refer to
the plumbers during Watergate no who
were they sold enough to remember
and
and when you've got folks whose job it
is to go find the derogatory information
about you and to extinguish it and when
those people are wearing FBI Badges and
can arrest people and coerce people it's
a concerning thing and uh that is going
to be Central to a lot of the
investigative work we do over these two
years or those those specific folks not
all of them still work for the federal
government so they can be subject to
Congressional subpoena a little easier
does it take does it take the the
Republicans and the the
populist Republicans in particular
controlling the Senate the house and the
presidency to think that anything can
get done on some things that's the case
well I was particularly thinking about
the FBI here they're telling me to back
off the mic bro
it's too soft
the uh the sound board just randomly
stopped working I went to deep State
honestly they must have clearly have
come in and somehow got it uh it was
everything was set up and it was working
we were just sitting waiting and then
around like 7 30 all of a sudden we're
watching the soundboards go off and so
we're like okay we have no idea what
happened so then we did this duct tape
solution and it worked we did a Snapchat
let me go live and all of a sudden it
just dropped again and we're like game
sounds way too high but that's it's not
the game's not even up it's you gotta
have the board may be failing in real
time maybe that's it I have no idea but
uh in real time
I'm not like the kind of guy that's like
cut the head off the thing repeal the
Federal Reserve Act repeal uh Obama
repeal the Patriot Act I would like
those things to be repealed I just feel
like trying to slice it open is just
gonna kill everything so like how do you
why do you peacefully I would reject
that premise
I I think that you actually have to
slice it open
and I think that you you've got to go
through the authorized and unauthorized
activities programmatically and you have
to observe what is the really important
stuff and there is that you know there
there are cyber crime divisions at the
FBI that get people's money back for
them when they're the victims of some
Chinese uh you know phishing attack in
their email and like those people are
patriotic Americans the problem is an
increasing amount of this intelligence
gathering got weaponized politically and
frankly you go back to the founding of
the FBI they were pretty political they
were just going after leftists they were
going after Malcolm X and Martin Luther
King Jr and Marcus Garvey
and when Obama was President they did a
terrific job of vertically integrating
their HR and they got a lot of talented
activists leftists into the system into
middle management and now those people
are kind of running the place
oh good mostly at least what it's
America it's a it's a Capitol Hill
way better
I I was like how does it you know
whatever how do you define leftists
well I think that those who believe in
government control as opposed to those
who believe in control democratized
among the people that's that's always
what my dad told me about the difference
between the right and the left he said
Son the left believes in the power of
government to solve people's problems
and we believe in the power of people to
solve their own problems
I think that like at the political
Compass there's the left and the right
and then there's the authoritarian and
the libertarian and I feel like the
authoritarian like so up on the
political Compass is like I want the
government to take care of it but I
could be like a leftist Libertarian
where I'm like do whatever you want
smoking those people well those people
used to that's like the Glenn greenwalds
right would you put him I think so he's
a traditional liberal where they used to
be a center left face essentially what
you're describing like a classical
liberal who believes in open flow of
information
the the reason left Libertarians are so
rare is because the best way to describe
a left libertarian is a hippie on a farm
he and his friends are sitting around
and then he comes in one day and he's
like hey guys I grew some watermelons
you want to share them and they're like
yeah and they break it and share it and
they're like anybody can come and go as
they please we all here and we all work
together and it only really works when
you have a group of people who are
socially cohesive and morally cohesive
it doesn't scale up at all so there's no
large organizational left libertarianism
it's not possible the right finds their
decentral right libertarianism finds it
through through Capital through trade
they agree don't hurt me I won't hurt
you everything's going to be voluntary
trade but if you're going to do
community oriented stuff it has to be
through moral agreement which is almost
impossible and only really works and you
have like 20 people so you're not going
to see a lot of them do you think like
libertarianism only functions if the
society's cohesive in general I'll put
I'll put it this way and a question for
you Matt maybe you agree I believe that
if every I'll I'll be as offensive as I
can about about it for the atheists in
the left I believe that if every single
person in this country was a devout
Christian
Church going God fearing you would need
no laws and no police you would have
them already and the people would
believe in adherence to those laws in
the absence of government because they
would they would believe in that which
is stronger more powerful and above
government and then what happens is as
you get by the way that that essentially
was the government right in the founding
days of uh of American Life said the
same thing Madison but I'm not but I'm
not saying literally we should be a
Christian theocracy in any way that I
try to say that the most shocking way to
this is atheists as possible if every
single person in this country was woke
you also would not need police because
you'd have woke activists going on
enforcing these things by choice without
pay if there wasn't a lot of freedom in
the Chas that's right uh well some
people died they had freedom to do that
apparently and then no accountability
but uh when you get a group of people
that all agree with the same thing
instantly the moral foundations are kick
in the problem is it doesn't scale up so
you end up needing some kind of law
enforcement apparatus then you need
police then you need jails and it as you
and as you bring in more opposing moral
ideologies you will need more police as
Society grows bigger you will need more
laws and then I think it eventually just
implodes well no no you got this all
wrong because the Silicon Valley Bank
says that the way to success is a
commitment to increasing racial ethnic
and gender representation ah cool that
worked out really well for him yeah I
mean this is a this is a message from
their CEO on their website and you can
actually go download their Dei reports
so that you can see how focused and
committed they are to Dei Investments
and you can go and see all that they're
doing to achieve their carbon neutrality
by 2025 which is very likely at this
point I I would bet on uh the Silicon
Valley Bank achieving total carbon
neutrality very soon so way to go for
the record svb's in a financial Free
Fall it's a bank in California that just
went under essentially I mean I don't
know it is more than that it is the
financial wing of Silicon Valley I mean
this is one of a top 20 Bank in the
country and over like 96 of all the
deposits aren't insured how familiar are
you with the topic to you yeah they're
not insured not they're because the
deposits are among all these Silicon
Valley uh firms and individuals and
businesses they they they are not
insured at you know they're not like
they don't have the FDIC yeah over 90 of
the money in that bank isn't coming back
but it's not just that FDIC on the
insurance which I think 250 per
signatory yeah and so if you if you're
one person this is the craziest thing if
you're in your business with One Bank
you're in trouble because if you've got
five accounts one let's say one is
you're like General uh uh payroll
expenses one is equipment and you
separate them in a certain way
it's only 250. that's it so if that bank
goes under your business no longer
exists and I'm going to cut you out a
quarter million dollars depending on the
size obviously but I'm saying if you're
Silicon Valley and you got 15 to 50
million
all gone all gone
the calls for the Silicon Valley bank
bailouts will be coming soon oh already
Andrew Yang has called for the federal
government to backstop Silicon Valley
bank to save the industry Yang already
where would we be if the CEO wasn't so
focused on uh diversity Equity inclusion
and ESG who's going to fund this if not
the American taxpayer yeah
man yeah yeah I'll step out you want to
step out for a minute and then I'll no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no you gotta be an authority no he wants
to step out all right I'll be back he'll
be back what's up dude yeah hop on in
man
do you want to introduce yourself for
everybody who's listening yeah I'm Dan
Bishop I represent 8th District from
North Carolina right Honest so uh
man we got some news on January 6th or
we want to wait for Matt to come back
I'm I'm good I think you know nobody
replaces Matt Gates no I guess he's just
Firebrand what happened
only Tim cast and Firebrand would have
kept me in Washington for another night
all right on man I appreciate it yeah
Matt was saying that uh everybody the
final vote was like 10 a.m so everybody
flew home yeah but he was like but Dan
was down he didn't want to leave we're
doing some work so what'd you guys do
today
you know we uh we've been uh we went
over gosh you know Matt can describe
this so much better than I can but we
went over to
this other nondescript building where
there's where the Congressional offices
have space
and we uh kind of rifle through the
January 6 committee
documents
I'm gonna step out Matt you I want you
Matt to talk about this a little bit
Matt can tell us back come on Matt can
you get around behind you brother all
right man
so you've got some some some Secrets
some breaking news well Well here here's
the thing Matt here's the news we got
for you okay everyone has been
appropriately focused on these videos
that Tucker Carlson's been releasing
from January 6th but Dan and I got to
thinking there was a lot of paper
created during this investigation the
subpoenas the demands for records it
showcases the strategy of how the
January 6 committee would go after a
Target who was working with them who did
they hire uh to collaborate on this
project it's about two million documents
and I think as far as I know Dan and I
are the first Republican lawmakers to
actually go and spend an extended period
of time going through this information
and here's what we can tell you about it
it's not disorganized
I kind of expected on the way out the
door Liz Cheney and Adam kinzinger might
have just opened their binders and
thrown everything into a giant bin
shaken it a few times and said You know
here here are your documents and you
know what this will this will drive you
crazy every Committee in Congress gets
to Define what a committee record is and
what has to be maintained so if they
wanted to the January 6th committee
could have said you know what the
committee records are the public
transcripts of our hearings and
everything else we're destroying and we
would have had no paper trail but
interestingly enough they kept not all
but almost all of the outgoing paperwork
product that they had developed the
letters that they'd sent people the
documents they'd requested the subpoenas
they drafted so all this outgoing the
way that they would Target not just you
but your internet service provider
they'd go to your Telecom company
Verizon they go to your bank and we saw
enormous collaboration between some of
these Fortune 100 companies financial
institutions alphabet and the January 6
committee eager to turn over the private
information of individuals are these
digital files these were hard paper
files that we observed now we're we're
like you're manually turning Pages oh
absolutely yeah are there 60 years 80
sort of small boxes of stuff and some of
it's uh public reports that Matt made
mention of but there's some interesting
stuff but I mean here's what's missing
what's missing is all the paper that was
supposed to come back you see all this
out going was supposed to generate lists
of people's emails texts and we were
able to review some of what came back as
a consequence of those results but
there's a huge dearth there they chose
to get rid of some of those records and
some others were going to chat about it
I'd be interested obviously I have a
personal stake but
how uh they discussed the media
Independent Media that have been talking
about it for me uh it was uh Raskin who
it's funny because he reps the district
right next to where we work out of and
some of our employees are in his
district and he took a clip of me
reading a Fox news headline and played
it alongside someone calling for kicking
in the doors or a red wedding and it's
me being like Donald Trump says there's
going to be a wild night well you know
maybe he's right I mean his supporters
are pretty angry and then he makes it
seem as he says these people were
calling for it I'm curious to see if
behind the scenes they were targeting
independent commentators social media
personalities I assume the answer is yes
they are the masters of the smear oh
yeah they always get their man that way
and you know we'll see what there's some
other there's some interesting Matt sort
of alluded to it there's there are
interesting pointers in the papers that
we saw to finding some other stuff it
could be the mother logo well and
another thing I learned going through
the January 6 committee's work product
is that there is a value at times to a
subpoena even if you aren't seeking
information back as a result of that
subpoena an example is how they what
they dealt with social media companies
imagine being a social media company and
getting subpoena in demand saying show
me everything you're doing to get these
extreme views off of your platform show
me everything you're doing to stop the
next Insurrection show me everything
you're doing to look at the profile of
people who support building the wall and
election integrity and the Second
Amendment and you know let us know that
you're actually being good corporate
citizens you see that's not a subpoena
intended to actually get usable
information back it's coercive in nature
and and they were using those tactics
and the level of detail
and vertically integrated subpoena
strategy was Exquisite let me give you
any let me give you an example Tim
they subpoenaed the catering company for
this building that we are in right now
for January 5th and January 6th to see
like if you had people over on January
5th how many cupcakes were delivered
that night and what does that say about
how many people were in a meeting in
your office
so
can you release these documents to the
Press
well we observed them and went through
them today with the permission of the
house administration committee they are
the committee with jurisdiction over the
records of the house and they're working
to get this digitized they have had a
very pro-transparency Outlook but we are
our patience is not one of our virtues
we it's March and we need to start
getting to this information analyzing it
seeing how Americans were targeted Dan
and I are very focused on our work on
the weaponization subcommittee and I
believe the January 6 committee was a
weaponized utilization of the American
government against our people and and
actually it spawned activity from the
Department of Justice that I remain
concerned about to this day I'm gonna
I'm gonna
I I'm just going to come out and say I
think
sometimes you guys maybe because you
have to give a little bit of a little
bit of the benefit of the doubt to some
of your Democrat colleagues because you
have to I'd imagine uh me I'm under no
such constraints and I think they're
evil people maybe maybe you wouldn't go
as far but the idea that they had access
to this footage that wasn't released
that some of these defendants never got
access to it they tried claiming the
defendants did but they didn't and it
shows a very different picture the fact
that Tucker Carlson in his report when
he came out and showed the video of
chancelly calmly walking through with
police trying to open a door for him
the first thing Tucker Carlson did in
that report was show the violence and
said we've all seen the violence in the
vandalism because we've been shown it
non-stop but here's what you didn't see
what did the the Democrats and the media
do in unison right away instead of
Cherry Picked he cherry-picked and he
lied and he didn't show the violence
because they know their audience will
never actually watch a full Tucker
segment where he does first and foremost
say yes there's violence that's exactly
right I'm sorry I think it's evil
because they've done evil there's no
question about it and if we did that
there would be actions to take our law
licenses away in North Carolina and
Florida if we went out there to Spur
criminal prosecutions and purposefully
withheld material evidence certainly if
we did it in a court of law they
distorted evidence repeatedly during the
course of the January 6 things I mean
you remember Jim Jordan's uh tweet where
they took it he had he had quoted
someone sent something that was quoted
they took the quotes off and made it as
if it were Jim Jordan's statement it was
nothing wrong with the statement
particularly anyway but it gave put
words in his mouth that didn't exist
I was thinking of going to raskin's
office after I saw he did this but you
know I got to tell you
um when when he played that clip of me I
had people I know who are Urban liberal
liberals in Chicago and it was a red
pill moment for them because they were
like my parents were watching this they
saw this clip I saw that and I
immediately was like that's Tim Poole
they're like
like he's like a like a boring fence
sitter guy that's messed up and it
immediately said to them like
something's not right with this picture
yeah so all of a sudden I get these
these liberals that I know being like
I'm not questioning what happened after
I saw that and I actually wrote an op-ed
for Newsweek because Newsweek reached
out to me and they were like we're
familiar with your content this doesn't
seem to make sense so that was a mistake
they smeared too hard and look I is it I
personally I get accused of being a
left-wing radical and a right-wing
radical on like a weekly basis isn't
that kind of your thing so in the early
days on the milk toast fence sitter
that's that's the gag because I'm like
well you know and I still I put it like
this you're an extreme moderate you're a
moderate Rebel maybe like all those
moderate rebels in Syria we've been
giving ours to I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
just gonna I'm just gonna say it uh
reality has a right-wing bias these days
that's the old joke from Colbert you
know reality has a left-wing bias I
guess that's what he said all those
years ago but
the the conversation that we're having
right now isn't based on our views on
policy I'm not here discussing with you
pro-life pro-choice tax policy flat tax
progressive tax we're talking about the
facts of January 6. information that was
withheld
and that makes you right wing
if the funniest thing about this modern
political landscape is I'm right wing
because I supported the narrative that
conservatives were facing undue
censorship on social media which is so
it's so confirmed now that you're you
you have the the attempts to smear Matt
taibi as a so-called journalist right
who's this like long-standing liberal
award-winning journalist for 30 years
they're calling Matt tabial a right
winger you've seen you've seen people
call him a right-wing you know
journalist like I've seen it the
Democrats attacked him with gusts yeah
yeah well I mean that's played it that
was an embarrassment to be honest with
you the the fact that the Democrats had
were trying to get the the journalists
to give up their sources and trying
multiple times over and over and
honestly there's part of me that thinks
that they didn't realize as if they
didn't possess the cognitive octane to
actually understand that they were
trying to get them to give up their
sources they didn't understand the
context and it was painful a couple of
them like
there's multiple layers to this right
the initial layer is you're watching
Democrats attack a long time Rolling
Stone journalist and a guy who's waving
his hand saying I voted for Biden yeah
you know I am not part of Hillary
Clinton's so-called vast right-wing
conspiracy and I think that's easy to
absorb but I think the additional layer
to it is how comprehensive the
censorship industrial complex is that's
what I really want people to take away
from this that this isn't like you know
a few bad actors in one agency this is
enterprise-wide in government the
Department of Homeland Security the
Department of Defense the Department of
Justice even the post office has a
covert program to monitor the political
views of people on social media and so
we got to get our head around that and
rather than patting ourselves on the
back for holding hearings about it we
have to use this process to inform how
we fund the government and one of the
things Dan and I fought really hard for
during the speaker's race was to have
individualized assessments of these
agencies
and it sounds dorky and wonky but I am
tired of voting on some multi-thousand
page bill that spends over a trillion
dollars that funds the government for
the entire year and you don't get to say
okay at a programmatic level here in DOD
FBI how do we excise that out exactly we
like vetoes what's that there should be
line vetoes like there should be
different oh line item veto yeah
absolutely I I would
enthusiastically support that under any
a president Republican or Democrat yeah
they're digitizing the January six files
all right
is there is there a capability or is
there a security risk like can this be
released to the public maybe maybe the
answer is more like a Twitter file style
approach where some journalists can come
in go through it with you guys and then
redact for security issues things that
might put people in In Harm's Way but
get this information out to the American
people so as to the my favor more
disclosure across the board I think
that's the one of our biggest problems
you talked about evil and you talked
about Democrats evil we're talking about
a bigger evil and this is spread across
all these government departments working
together with these with academic pseudo
academics and so forth that Matt was
talking about but yeah I think
um they thrive in secrecy and and that
is a general proposition can these
things all be released there's some
things we saw on there I'm not sure
could a few items but most of it should
be why not let's use the you ought to
see what this Committee of Congress
decided they could go do pick a target
maybe I'll take their name off but show
the bank that and the and the the is is
as Matt was saying earlier today they've
picked a Target and then they went and
figured out all their finances they went
and figured out all their means of
communication they figured out all their
means of movement it it's it is
otherworldly and you can't believe that
kind of thing goes on the United States
the way to stop it is for people to know
that it happens and I I should clarify
too I suppose
there were there were Republicans on
that on that panel I mean not the
Republicans anyone actually wanted to be
in today yeah but you had kinzinger and
Cheney who you know exactly in name and
as far as anyone was concerned they were
effectively Democrats but that really
says a lot one thing I noticed was that
the Republicans had extraordinary
influence over the committee we got into
some of the January 6 committee's staff
files and one thing I took particular
note of is that Adam kinzinger was able
to place a hand-picked CIA lawyer into
the general counsel's office of the
House of Representatives to Gaslight or
like all these subpoenas to torch
Americans to smear them and and they
were assembling people not from the
traditional group that you would think
for Congressional staff but they were
finding sharp tooth lawyers in the
Department of Justice the FBI the CIA
high-end State Attorney's offices they
were finding people all over the country
they were bringing high-end left-wing
talent in to operationalize that force
all right let's uh I'm gonna ask you
guys the the hard question I suppose
where's the committee on far left
extremism antifa we talk about January 6
and uh the the unjust actions that were
taken for a lot of these people look
some of these people I think were
violent should be criminally charged you
know like I said Tucker shows the
violent footage but just uh this in this
past week in the past few months we've
had we had a group of 150 far left
extremists break into a government
compound a facility in Georgia fire bomb
buildings and equipment
some of these people were not from this
country one of them was a lawyer for the
Southern Poverty Law Center
the Southern Poverty Law Center admitted
it and said that oh he's a legal
Observer and then the spokesperson
tweets out a a hashtag in support of the
terrorists these people have been
charged with domestic terrorism
how is it that the entire cycle
the news cycle I understand the media is
going to ignore it but where are we in
terms of putting together the select
committee on far left extremism how
about we have the May 29th Insurrection
panel the select committee on the May 29
on 529 and we can talk about the
follow-up extremists who tore down the
barricades of the White House fire
bombed a guard posts that fire to St
John's Church injuring I think around 70
70 to 100 police officers forcing the
president into a bunker how about we get
we bring cops in to testify on that cops
who are injured we bring in Witnesses
and journalists and we put all of that
on the record
so I'm here for it understand though
remember that in a lot of ways the two
parties do the same thing in Washington
and so the only reason we have a select
committee on the weaponization of
government is because when Matt and I
said we're going to negotiate over who
gets to be the speaker we're not just
going to cast votes just because
180 of the members Republican members
say we're going to do it that was great
by the way well I mean you know the
first couple days it wasn't so great
yeah but uh I mean for us but I thought
it was important to do so Matt we stuck
to our guns that's really the first time
people have
there have been a lot of coup efforts I
guess you'd call them if you want to
call it that I wouldn't it's a bad word
that's a bad word that's what they call
it that's a friend of ours in Congress
called it from multiple coup efforts
against the uh you know they call this
the Taliban 20. yeah yeah yeah that is
the coolest nickname I have ever been a
partner said we were in legislative
terrorists but but that was it was we
stuck to our guns and uh and and part in
a a very material part of the agreement
that we in fact I negotiated The
Authority for that subcommittee myself
and um and and uh so these aren't easy
to get in the sense that a lot of people
want to
ignore stuff and yeah the question will
be to what extent were U.S taxpayer
dollars used to try to fuel some of
those groups through ngos through a lot
of this diversity equity and inclusion
funding that we do I think we got our
next guest here man all right Steve yeah
yeah we'll uh we'll rotate down and uh
let the honey badger join us so I think
the mics I I see people saying pull the
mic back I push the mic way back because
it looks like they're very sensitive on
top of them or something I guess the
they're picking up very they're picking
up too well now okay of course right
right it was like really quiet we're
like trying to get closer we're like
pull away pull away gotcha but uh is
that is that Joel Steve coming in Steve
ended Tim cast five you got to get
accustomed to that
I blame the Deep State for the audio
problems it happened last time no the
last time we had the audio problem look
at this Steve Bannon the honey badger in
the Capitol it doesn't get any better
never met the man myself hey Dan Bishop
how you doing honor good to meet you so
we'll let Bannon get seated we're
talking about Dan and my trip to
go through all of the January 6th
committee documents uh Adam kinzinger
was able to get they sent their two
right guys well it's We Believe today
was the first time that any lawmakers
are you going to host and direct to
direct the whole thing yeah absolutely
uh so here's what we were talking about
and I'm curious in your thoughts uh Mr
Bannon
uh some kind of antifa committee or at
least a component of exploring the far
left extremism we're actively seeing
right now
we I think we get two things out of it
one accountability for what we saw in
Georgia what we saw in Portland what we
saw with Chaz and all that stuff
it's accountability uh we could stop
what's actively going on if we shine a
light on it we can get accountability
for the past actions and then I think it
might wake up a lot of Americans to the
degree of violent extremism coming from
the left that's not being portrayed in
Media
I think that's a great idea I think what
we need is to put all the effort into
reconstituting a j6 committee
and let them have a ranking member in a
minority Council and set it all up and
go back to the beginning I think I think
that's one of the biggest things in the
country and I think you need top people
like we have here on this committee and
it's all the information has got to come
out on the intelligence services on the
FBI everything what we knew what we
didn't know all of it I mean Tucker did
a thing don't get me wrong the F the
antifa's needed too but I only think
we've got
so much bandwidth to do things and this
is this is this has to be answered yeah
it can't continue on like it is you
can't continue to rely on guys like
Tucker doing a heroic job with the 44
000. we need a formal investigation
a select committee if you have to of
major players in the Democratic Party in
the Republican party not like the show
trial she had but actually have a
ranking member you've said that a few
times yeah and and it is a decision
point we are at right now because
Democrats have used their presence in
these transcribed interviews to obstruct
the investigation yes to try to deter
whistleblowers to smear patriotic
Americans who joined the premier law
enforcement agency in the world because
they love our country as we all should
and I don't think they should get to
participate anymore in those transcribed
interviews if they are using that
courtesy to try to do harm to the
investigation and you're saying bring
them in due to them better than they did
I just think look I I think in that
regard they play Smash Mouth I think we
have to start playing Smash Mouth right
but I think you have to cons if you
don't constitute it where they get the
information are able to cross-examine
Witnesses we're gonna have the exact
same show trial we had the first time
Steve these are such deep issues
but the American people have to get to
the but we have to get to the bottom of
this this is like Watergate this is like
Iran Contra this is like the 911
Commission you know they always say it's
like Pro per Harbor had seven different
commissions four of them in the Capitol
right and they still never quite got to
think but they kept going over and over
because the American people deserve
answers we deserve the American people
deserve answers even if you guys and I
think there's enough tough guys like
yourself that can get in there and make
sure they're not leaking depositions
they're not playing games with the press
all of that it's gonna be tough but it's
I think it's going to happen one thing I
found interesting when we went through
the files today they are incredibly well
organized and as it relates to outgoing
documents they are almost completely
complete you can go through by name you
can pull uh the I pulled the Charlie
Kirk file and I saw the way that the
Turning Point organization was targeted
and is actually still being unfairly
targeted I pulled the Bernie Carrick
file and saw the way they went after him
I I you know pulled the mark short file
and I saw how eager he was to cooperate
and how even with friendly Witnesses
they they played this game with the
subpoena nonetheless but there was one
file
with no documents in it that I reviewed
and it was the Steve Bannon file no
documents there was the states
they've taken it it's waiting for me in
federal prison for my four-month
sentence right the warden will have it I
I in a I'm sure justice has it in a
circumstance where they were so
meticulous to have everything indexed
and included and in in almost every case
you saw a letter and like clockwork
within 14 days a subpoena that followed
that letter
and nothing on the Bannon Fox so it's
empty it is a file there is it there we
found the seed bathroom nothing there
man well I actually I I not to get my
trials and appeal but I I think if you
did it's not that what what I would want
to do j6 but there's no doubt that the
to me the uh The General Counsel for the
committee perjured herself multiple
times in my trial to have a general
account say oh I didn't know that was
happening I didn't know it's just it's
it's Beggar's belief it's incredible
well and also for this person uh we we
are we are looking at the members and
records and I want to know how far they
cross the line when we exercise our
subpoena power because what I observed
was that almost every week this the
committee was sending out to Sprint
Verizon T-Mobile to Google Voice
all of these phone numbers I want all of
their records yes all of these bank
accounts all these Amex cards all the
the PayPal accounts people had wanting
all of the records it was such a wide
Dragnet and I wonder whether or not some
of these phone numbers are going to
match up to members of Congress yes I
wonder if they're going to match our
staffs it was interesting to see that
the subpoenas depicted
there must have been some very good
conversation going on between big tech
companies big telecom companies and the
committee because the committee would
send out a subpoena to the to the banks
and it would say it would ask for these
internal file numbers of the bank and
they'd give like 30 file numbers
right but they nonetheless then
subpoenaed it uh and got it so but you
know that kind of relationship is pretty
but that even of itself
even if you don't reconstitute the
committee which I strongly recommend you
guys do just to put that in front of the
American people
of how gun deck this thing was right how
organized it was with with these parts
but what Tim is saying is that we need
to pick up these tools and and use them
to deconstruct what is a dangerous
weaponized left 100 what uh well so for
for one I I I'm fascinated by the fact
that we have active anti-fotera right I
you know I hate to say antifa it's far
left it's it's a plethora of of of
groups or whatever actively firebombing
houses they flip the guy's truck over
random guy flip this truck over set on
fire they shot a cop this is escalating
for a French and a Canadian guy were
involved NGO lawyer was involved so we
have that actively happening but but I
do agree I think
for what I think the American people
aren't being told what's going on
because it's being ignored by the Press
because it's bad for them they want to
side with their audience and I think we
can force them to cover it if we had
some kind of hey look we're going to do
the same thing at the same time
I'd love it if you guys subpoenaed Ray
apps
I don't know that would have to be part
of it that I think you have to use the
facial recognition and go to the DHS and
go you have to find out how many federal
agents were there yes there was
obviously federal agents you have to
have I mean my point is you have to go
back to the beginning and find out what
people knew until I had Chris Miller the
acting Secretary of Defense at the time
you know he was on the show he had a
book came out it's 300 pages long 20
Pages deal with this situation I think
I'm the only guy who read it because
he's got explosives he he as secretary
of defense couldn't get anybody
organized in FBI or just anything to
even have a meeting to plan on security
he just keeps watching TV so he finally
called they would meet on Sunday
afternoon before the Tuesday
I think January 2nd or 3rd he uh has a
zoom call now this is the acting
Secretary of Defense he's got the FBI
doj all of it and uh they're sitting
there going yeah we have intelligence
there's going to be 35 000 people there
and he goes gosh they had a million in
in November 12th they had 75 000 on the
14th he says oh we've done this we got
until the 35 000. and he goes well you
know can we help can we get troops can
we get National Guard I can get all the
stuff in the any and that he was told no
the D.C metro and Capitol Hill Police
can handle up to a million protesters
and and it's fine and that won't be
that'll be fine and he says well how
many Mario Bowser finally asked for 325
National Guard which he deployed to
Andrews Air Force Base wouldn't even
learn to find God didn't want him in the
city Andrews Air Force Base which is you
know 45 miles minutes away traffic he
goes to the White House next day for
Trump on another separate meeting
and Trump's sitting there and you know
they get there it's another man I think
they're going to pull the troops out of
Korea right so he's leaving and Trump
goes hey are you ready for tomorrow and
he goes well I think we are sorry he
says what are you know what are you
doing he says well we've had this big
meeting and I've got 325 troops here go
to Andrews and Trump goes now you're
going to need 10 000. you should call up
10 000. it's in the book right there he
says Trump said you're going to need 10
000 you should get him up
he says well they don't want it the
mayor doesn't want it Nancy Pelosi
doesn't want it nobody wants it two what
degree nobody nobody in the country
knows that that's why we committed you
go back to the beginning committee
didn't didn't put in the report but they
had their Chief investigator goes to NBC
after the things closed up and said and
and puts the information out about the
government that the agencies did know
all that was going to happen and that
they didn't uh so I want to ask you
Steve to what degree do you believe that
this was
either uh let to happen by the federal
government or actually incited by the
federal government themselves
well the War Room agents of the war room
as you know is right in back of the
Supreme Court you know we're like a
block away and I found it stunning on
that day I never left the worm did the
morning show get rid of the afternoon
show but guys told me they had basically
deployed the Capitol Hill Police into
bike racks there was nothing there and I
just found that to be stunning given the
fact that people knew it was going to be
a big March Etc so I don't know it's all
speculation what I'd like to get well
here's what worries is the facts in
front of and let the Democrats
cross-examine guys see the stuff let
them I'm sure they're going to leave
some stuff but if you got even if you
got some of the original j6 people back
up there and cross-examine them
cross-examine like the Hutchinson
cross-examine these people under penalty
of perjury you might get some very
different stories and I think that's
necessary because I think Trump was
smeared you know Soup To Nuts in this
thing
yeah I I I I think that uh there's a a
criminal Acuity that may have been
increased by some of these FBI assets
and here's the incentive structure that
creates that we were talking earlier in
the program about how the FBI changed in
culture to an intelligence collection
organization and so what they would do
is they would seed assets into a lot of
these groups that they thought were
dangerous the three percenters the proud
Boys The Oath Keepers and then the
incentive structure for that person
informing back to the FBI is for that
group to seem as significant as possible
and so you know do I believe that
Christopher Ray was giving an order to
somebody you know wearing a federal
badge to commit a crime on that day no
but I think they created an incentive
structure where some of their assets
confidential informants confidential
human sources that were baked into these
groups tried to facilitate and encourage
a higher level of criminal Acuity and by
the way it sounded reasonable to think
that because that's what we saw in the
Whitmer case you've covered exactly
you've covered Michigan better than
anybody and that's exactly what the
Whitmer case is it's a perfect example
and that and by the way many people in
the Whitmer case at the senior levels
were here it just looks like it was a it
was Bloody Kansas to the Civil War it
was kind of the Preamble The microcosm
of the thing it's just like like a dry
like a trial balloon it just I don't
know and the country doesn't know and
the Very Special Agent in charge who ran
the Whitmer investigation in Michigan
field office and if you look at the
deposition of Ray Epson you compare it
to I mean the trying to guide his
testimony it's just it's just it Beggars
belief there's not something there and
you need a formal process all I'm saying
is go back to what Congress really does
well to have these big complicated
special countries where you get
Watergate the Pearl Harbor commission
911 commissioner Commission on a 2008
financial crisis and it's always the
same cookie cutter that's what they had
it's one of my appeals one of the big
fights was I not just executive
privilege but also about the
construction of the committee they came
down to one word shall versus will and
we're going to appeal that because the
committee was you you try to put up
Jordan and Banks he's she said no and
then McCarthy you know for made a
decision just let go and they never had
a ranking member and most importantly
never had a minority Council never saw
the evidence and never got to cross it
can you imagine what j6 would be like
that show trial that did cross-examining
these Witnesses
you practice law would you have ever
lost a case if there wasn't an opposing
lawyer I mean I
law there was no opposing there were
always the war stories about losing the
unopposed motion to extend time right
but no that that really didn't happen
to represents what is it a man who
represents represents himself as a fool
for a client yeah yeah you're going up
against a pro and you don't know what
you're doing one of the things that
makes me a bit more conspiratorial on
January 6 but I won't say into knowing
just you know I have questions is
if someone came to me and it was like
let's say I was working for like a
shadowy organization and uh deep
intelligence or whatever and they said
we need to guarantee that Donald Trump
wins his re-election I would say here's
what you do when the activists show up
on May 29th you'll let him win you let
him tear the fences down you let him
burn the church down then you will have
two years of non-stop coverage of the
far left terror attack that ransacked
and destroyed Washington DC destroyed an
iconic Church forced the president to a
bunker and breach the White House and
then January 6 happened and I'm like how
about that when when the protesters came
to DC that's what you're saying it's not
so much my idea I mean they followed
that that course that's what it seems
like because
after what happened on May 29th I mean
you had what was it like I mean hundreds
of thousands there's photos of an aerial
photo of DC with smoke rising up they
set fire to St John's Church a historic
church but Trump stopped it Trump and
Barr stopped it and it wasn't even the
most brutal Crackdown I've ever seen in
terms of protest in the United States
they put their shoes I think it was Bill
Barr's best moment but here's the thing
media attack them for stopping it right
exactly they said it was a brutal tear
gas now you're a brutalized people Trump
protesting Retreats the bunker and says
I was just checking it out and the media
mocks him for it but imagine what would
have happened if the video footage was
Far leftist ripping down the fences in
front of the White House and the next
day Trump came out and didn't take a
picture with a Bible in front of the
standing church he took a picture with
police officers and firefighters in
front of an iconic historic church that
was burnt To The Ground by antifa that's
that's psyops that's that's
understanding the game
Trump I believe
I believe he's a True Believer I believe
the people he brought on for the most
part not everybody they're thinking like
hey we got to stop these extremists
let's do our job but then you look at
the people who are more nefarious and
more evil and they say no no no no no
let them let them in then you get these
videos coming out now of chance Lee the
cops are walking with them they try to
open one of the doors but they don't
show us I don't buy the theory at all
Bill Barton I don't think I think Bill
Bart did a terrible job there were no
tiger teams set up in any of those
cities Portland OR am to go with special
with special prosecutors that would
flood the zone and start indicting
people and arresting people I think the
justice department was terrible in the
entire time I I agree you disagree no my
I was facetious
moment was uh was Lafayette Square yeah
mostly a clown mostly a clown they
didn't set up any special Prosecuting
units they didn't flood the zone to
Chicago to Portland to Seattle anything
his best moment was Lafayette Square his
second best moment was the bagpipes
everything else was downhill from there
no no I agree with that and lastly by
the way after the photo op was one quite
frankly the crew really started as esper
says in his book he went back and talked
to Millie because the media got on him
and that's when they made an agreement
that they would control Trump they
wouldn't let Trump get out of control to
me they should have resigned with their
honest should have gone and resign to me
that is a absolute coup when they made
decisions and made decisions later on
about who they want to talk to in other
militaries Etc so it didn't go either
direction I suppose I should say the the
the 529 Insurrection as I like to call
it was was shut down and there was some
damage and they got mocked for it but
when it came to Chas and and the attempt
of these autonomous zones there was
nothing so I mean you have an
opportunity to either show the people
you're shutting down and we call it the
summer of love because the riots were
the worst we've seen in 50 years uh
um uh who was the Michael Tracy did
reporting I believe it's Michael Tracy
is his name he did the report I don't
think you can get that I don't think the
country actually wants to revisit that
I'll be blunt I think you have to if you
want to get there I think it needs to be
done we need to go back to that summer
and all those riots and get to the
bottom of particularly in the city but
other cities we're not we're not there I
think you've got to start
you listen Kamala Harris they just said
the other day walked up and they
compared it to Pearl Harbor in 9 11.
they say Pearl Harbor 911 and this if
it's at that level it should have a
formal investigation done the way that
Congress has done them from over 200
years and then once that's done I think
the American people because look four
million people watched Tucker the other
night and they're in shock and we only
got one night of footage in the Q Anon
Shaman and some things like that what
happens if you guys had several you know
eight weeks to prepare teams on it and
gave the Democrats so they could
cross-examine I would be galvanizing TV
first off it'd be the number one show in
the country while we don't have a
vehicle to do that now I don't know why
that couldn't be done and under the
selects uh subcommittee on weaponization
isn't that weaponization of government I
I think or oversight or whatever you
guys pick it but it to me it's I don't
know why it's not happening the j6 thing
is going to be a festering sort there
for the country and then I think in the
process of doing it they're going wow
what about these other things what about
this well it is a balance Steve because
I think one of the mistakes demo
Democrats made in our hearing this past
week was exclusively focusing on the
past so they wanted Dan Goldman wanted
to relitigate the Russia hoax they
wanted to relitigate the Ukraine
impeachment and we're talking about the
the type of society with a free exchange
of ideas that we want to be able to
preserve for the next generation and I
think it's it's a more we have to
balance the the need for justice
preservation of civil liberties with a
with a vision but I think the vision of
going forward congressman is the
following I think people would be
absolutely shocked when Congress got to
the bottom of what was the intelligence
of the intelligence Community does DHS
actually have a domestic intelligence
unit and were there Federal assets and
officers involved there that would shock
the country and going forward we said
we're not going to do this I already
reported it this is the our paper of
record as as you like to say on the War
Room
beloved paper a record
well I my recommendation is you until we
do that until you have a formal
investigation of j6 because look Murdoch
and these guys shut Tucker down he's the
biggest most powerful he didn't show any
more footage no and the next night you
could tell you and I talked about it
they they clearly put that show together
at the last second I mean he had the
Russell Brand thing from the day from
the Tucker today they they had Plug and
Play he's got a lot more footage a lot
more furniture when they ran Russell
Brand which was a pre-recorder from the
day of a interview they did on his on a
streaming show a brave front but uh but
there was no more no there's no more no
more original footage from this since
the first night they've had the mother
of the Q Anon Shaman and the lawyers on
that didn't get it but see doesn't this
footage have to be released to the
country and crowdsource it I think you
have to I think the notion of a security
of meaningful security risks is absurd
these are people walk around the capitol
every day people are taking pictures of
of this building on a moment by moment
basis so I think that's a red herring
and one thing I learned during the
Russia hoax is that you've got to get
information out and we have all of these
online sleuths that analyze and assemble
and Aggregate and promote and it is a
fool who believes that holding
information in for the perfect titrated
release is commanding the day actually
it's we really ought to be judged on the
volume of information we get before the
American people we did sit today at the
terminals that are set up that have the
videos that are all there and you know I
I I do not know how Tucker's staff were
able to sit down at those three
Terminals and go through you know what
is it forty Thousand Island yeah and a
lot of it you can eliminate it yeah sure
but you get a map can you see where all
the cameras are you can drive the first
two people of elected office actually to
go and go through the files we are to my
understanding we are the first two
Republican lawmakers that have had
access to the full Suite of files of the
jam or six committee yeah that's
probably can we get the footage to a
different news organization if Tucker
can't do it I you know this the
speaker's call well McCarthy told Boyle
I mean the Breitbart interview he told
Bo on the first question I'm going to
release it he says I'm gonna I'm gonna
release all this I'm gonna release it
all publicly so it's like I'm being an
archive and we're just down he said I'm
gonna release it to other every news
organization essentially he's not gonna
not gonna hold it tight as soon as I
guess Tucker's finished with this and
that there's obviously some decision
will be made shortly right yeah this all
has to inform the Appropriations process
though you know what Dan and I worry
about sometimes is that we're going to
do all this leg work we're going to
expose these facts we do not have the
ability to put handcuffs on anybody we
don't have the ability to charge anyone
with a crime any referral for criminal
prosecution that we send to Mayor
Garland is going to end up in the
circular van told me Mark Levinson on
the stage of CPAC after your speech
we're not going to defund the FBI that
we're not going to defund well well that
is that it's a ridiculous idea and we're
not going to do it we have to curtail
the abused authorities and then we have
to drain the blood out of out of this
place and that is going to mean using a
meat cleaver When approaching the FBI
budget not an exacto knife I think
that's exactly right do you get rid of
the FBI maybe you don't get rid of the
FBI but can you not look at them and see
they've got too much in the way of
resources they're too big they're too
omnipresents I'm okay with it lay out
your idea about breaking up the FBI
under the authority of the of the US I
think another problem another obvious is
that is all this decision making that
was the most I love Dan Bishop's idea
Mueller changes into a centralized
decision making and intelligence
gathering organization you need to
decentralize it you need to get rid of
the Washington field office you want to
look at the executive power you probably
need to separate out any intelligence
functions do you put the you put the
field offices under the U.S attorney
since that's what that was my proposal
let's let the U.S attorneys direct you
know be responsible for their
investigators which is the FBI you're
part of Florida in North Carolina
Carolina are two of the most
conservative parts of the country what
what do they have if you go back to them
and talk about restructured dramatically
restructuring and taking paths away from
the FBI what would they say standing
ovations I've got look I've done it I do
do that and and um this is something
that's very interesting to me coming to
Washington and I haven't been here I've
only been here four years almost
people out there it's amazing they're
very well informed and they are way
ahead of Washington they are way ahead
on every time understanding what needs
to be done and uh and they're not
they're not shy about saying that you
know so when chip Roy talks about
defunding woke and weaponized government
in Washington I think there's a cheering
cheering section out there and it's
really big and I was particularly
impressed with the uh big the hearings
with big Tech when uh you had Matt Tybee
being a so-called journalist and you
also had a woman who did not know what
sub step or who Mr Weiss was and I
thought to myself did they do five
minutes of Google prep before coming
into this this hearing no no Sylvia
Garcia is going to send a subpoena to
find out exactly how high the sub stack
is
not good well I mean how are we supposed
to solve these problems when you've got
people who come in clearly in bad faith
with no knowledge and claim it's not
happening but I don't know what you're
claiming is happening you know what I
mean the question is do they look like
clowns to the country as much as they do
to you too often yeah
they're bound to because they're
attacking I mean you can look I'm out of
I'm an older guys Matt taibi and and
Michael schellenberger everybody's
watching things
and Andrew went at it every day right
that shows you how far the country's
come right with taibi now being
basically a witness for honesty and
truth and yeah and this thing's gotten
out of control to me that was a huge
moment of course the mainstream media
didn't want to touch it because he's a
renowned guy a guy with real credentials
I feel like uh the way I describe it is
where this country is suffering from
hypoxia
one one hemisphere of this country's
brain has been starved of oxygen and
when you are suffering from hypoxia you
cannot save yourself because you don't
know
so they do these tests where they'll
reduce the oxygen level in a hyperbaric
chamber or something ask you math
questions the people think they're
answering right when they turn the
oxygen back up they look at scribbles
and chicken scratches and they're like I
thought I put the right answer down to
put the wrong numbers how are we
supposed to solve a problem when you
know you ask if if people are
see these people as clowns same way we
do I don't think they do I think they
may be completely demoralized no you're
too generous you're too generous hypoxia
isn't typically something that you do to
yourself I sometimes wonder with these
folks which stage of the ritualistic
self-mutilation exercise are we in at
this point
and especially you know on the war room
we talk a lot about China and as I
assess these Chinese capabilities that
we allow into our country like the
Balloon Mania I never really got because
we got what one in every four Americans
with tick tock on their phone we've got
a Chinese surveillance equipment at
almost every U.S Port where they are
able to get signals Intelligence on the
entire supply chain of the United States
we have Rural America being connected by
Chinese technology we have U.S police
stations flying Chinese drones and we're
gonna get worked up over like 1950s
technology
right everyone could see it so it was a
Scion I came on the War Room the day
after and said I thought that was a
total sign but a serious country would
not do these things a serious country
would not allow what's happening on the
border to happen and one of the thing
that things that's frustrated Dan and I
is that like we've got some of these
Republicans who will not vote for the
legislation necessary to jam the Biden
into a border strategy and we've got to
have a vote on chip Roy's legislation to
detain or turn away at the border and
let the chips fall where they may but we
are hearing now that there are folks who
say oh well if it won't pass we can't
bring it to the floor because that would
show weakness now you know what it would
show strength the strength of our ideas
they say that they say their concern is
that it'll show it will expose the
people who vote against that to losing
their seats why shouldn't we expose them
to it have other people replace them
look you guys I agree with you guys in
four days did more for this country than
it's been done on Capitol Hill in 40
years Steve that I I will not
take that praise because all we did was
develop a toolbox and and but that's
more than this that's more yeah
not just that you galvanized everybody P
everybody was watching is the number one
TV show it galvanized the country and
people realize you know because you were
so opposed by Fox and everybody at first
that you're it's not about you're not
bringing the country together you have
to have Unity everything like that and
you showed exactly what the problems are
and that you needed it's not an end unto
itself it's not it's the summit has not
been no no no no but no I didn't say
that my point is is that you guys always
have that weapon of how to take the the
magnificent six of the mighty 20 and do
it and do it again you know you're gonna
like you said the country is far behind
far ahead of where the city is in this
Capital you guys had the people have
your back you just have to be more
aggressive on how you do it you can't
there's no amount of aggressive action
you can take in Congress right now that
will not be rewarded by people saying I
like these guys I like what they said
like your thing on Syria
that
that you when you stood up and it was
the Republican it was interventions
Republicans who looked idiotic because
nobody actually heard a compelling case
how one Congress has to get this power
back and number two this is absurd of
what we're doing the neocon this the the
this whole neocon you know trying to
police the world that was a powerful
moment you guys just need more and more
and more I wouldn't pull punches you you
you you know you give McCarthy's guys a
some time but then you got to start and
I think you're going to have more people
up there realizing hey I got to be part
of this team because we're not
aggressive enough oh I want to give a
white pill I guess for all those who may
be discouraged I kind of feel like the
position I've been in for a long time
like as you're describing it no more
World Police I I believe in securing our
borders bringing jobs back bolstering
the American people all that stuff and I
I felt when I was younger that it didn't
exist at all it was the establishment
neocons and it was the corporate neolibs
now it feels like as much as sometimes
it feels like we're losing in some
respect this is actually the most I've
ever seen in terms of real opposition to
the machine machine especially in the
system the neoliberal neocon world order
we've had for since World War II is
collapsing before our eyes right you can
see that whether it's the well chaos is
gonna I mean something's got to come out
of this and it's going to be a not
pleasant transition but from Silicon
Valley Bank right to what's happening in
Syria you've got the neoliberal part of
capitalism that is collapsing you've got
this situation in Ukraine and now you've
got the CCP just cut a deal with Iran
and our great allies Saudi Arabia to
basically take uh you take Chinese
currency you want instead of Petro
dollars the neoliberal neocon world
structure is collapsing before our eyes
okay and you never know where the next
shock is going to come from Silicon
Valley Bank Kramer was touting the stock
right a couple of weeks ago right you're
touting the stock as I go long as a buy
a couple of weeks ago no too good and by
the way the company's not trying to
raise a couple of billions and this
thing you don't know where the contagion
is going to be it caught everybody's
surprise the California Regulators had
to I said the day on the show at 10
o'clock I said this bank will not exist
by the close of business now what
shocked me was that the California
regulator stepped in before the FED
because yelling these guys don't want
this such a bad narrative for them about
what's happened to the bonds the
government securities all of it such a
terrible narrative that in this thing
remember you're going to have a thousand
great startups that are not going to
make payroll next week and they're going
to come right here it's 170 169 billion
dollars in deposits are uninsured wow
they're going to come right to the
Capitol next week and they're going to
ask flying over East Palestine Ohio it's
never got a ballot and they're coming
right here and say guys Innovation the
guy said we're gonna we're gonna fall
behind China by a decade in Innovation
because the best startup companies we we
have all bank here they're not going to
make payroll it's going to it's going to
collapse you think 72 hours ago nothing
we didn't know anything about this my
point is that's the neoliberal neocon
order is collapsing in front of you so
become a member at timcast.com so that
we can make payroll because I'm only
half kidding actually when whenever this
stuff hits
I mean we we see it and we we often see
it first because yes what happens is
when covet first hit all of these small
businesses the way ads work on YouTube
small mom and pop restaurant buys a
couple hundred bucks in ads for the
month that Target their local area
people will see it on Facebook or
Instagram or something but that all adds
up our video plays in that area it hits
those I would know Tim I've been banned
on YouTube that's right on every
platform but we how about you man still
on YouTube now by the way the only I got
strikes on YouTube only when I would
post my interviews on war room all of my
strikes are War Room strikes I want to
say right now we are seeing ad rates
dropping a lot really yeah we're seeing
these these layoffs in Silicon Valley
before svb yeah this news came out all
the tech layoffs yeah I'm looking at in
our ad rates so I'm just like be a
member because membership is a shield
for us and then with with ads dropping
the way they are this time of year it
feels like it's going to be a summer of
a very very dark Financial days now
we're saying this look I don't want to
be I don't want to say something that
could precipitate it by encouraging
people to Panic or anything like that
I'm just saying
I I agree with you that the world is the
neolib neocon system is breaking apart
that means the night is always the
darkest before the dawn I tell people to
get some chickens and get some emergency
food and learn how to take care of that
I tell the people first thing is when a
guy look this is madness this the
economic system we have today is madness
when Biden sits there as as when you
look at the depression of working-class
people in this country and they come up
this week everything we've been talking
about and they come up with uh 6.8
trillion dollar budget not one cut to
one program in fact the rate of increase
I think is almost six percent a 5.2
percent pay increase for federal
employees and across the board they have
they have at their own calculation what
train and half dollar deficits as far as
the aggregate the three trillion dollar
taxes which I my recommendation is the
house should meet tomorrow and Saturday
the Republicans they should pass every
tax increase they've got all of them
send it to the Schumer and the Democrats
and dare them to pass it you're gonna
see what phonies they are because it's
all their donors all the big hedge fund
guys are are there donors all the owners
all the billionaires are their donors
those billionaires hate Maga right and
then and by the way Schumer had the guts
to do it which you wouldn't do it Biden
would veto it because it's all his all
his sponsors
I'm for more than the wealth tax when
you have one wealth tax I'm more than
that no I want the briefs I want the
repatriation look when you have one
percent of the people citizens own more
Assets in the bottom 90. that system
can't sustain itself greed if the
Revolutionary generation came back they
would spit on the floor they fought a
revolution to get away from a landed
aristocracy and the mercantilist system
of the monopolies of the British East
India Company and others like it that's
what John Adams and Sam Adams and
Hancock were Smugglers the rest were
smart lawyers they said we want our own
deal we're not going to do that if they
came back and said you guys allowed this
to devolve into an oligarchy are you
kidding me we're one percent of the
people this is exactly what they fought
the revolution for it even the elites
even among the revolutionaries yeah
there was a sense of Duty yes that was
expected exactly and that's what we lack
today and I don't know how you guys I
don't know how you reignite that sense
of patriotism I feel like I think I
think the way I think the way you do it
is what you guys did in the first week
of of uh of uh uh January
but even that when you had everybody in
conservative media against you when you
had Fox News against you we had oh it's
unity and you guys are terrible guys and
I gotta tell you we came that close on
that Friday night at 10 o'clock to Total
Victory right it was that it was hung in
the balance so it's it's
I think people get patriarch when they
see that when they see action they love
their country go out in the hinterland
in your constituents they're so far
ahead of where we are it's not true but
they understand the details they
understand what's going on because it
shows like uh Tim pool and so many other
podcasts out there that get the
information out to people and they're
hungry for information they will immerse
themselves if you put up different links
to go to they will start I give homework
assignments over the weekend people will
read it and come back it'll be informed
or be asking questions in the chat rooms
Etc so people want the patriotism the
DNA of our Revolution is still with us
right right it's still with us remember
there's only a third of the guys in the
in the revolution on our side right
there's a third Tories a third of
ourselves and a third in the middle like
there always is to say hey I'm gonna see
how this thing plays out that's the
resilience of the country the resilience
exactly they can take institutions over
but they can't really change that and
the people can step forward and do it
fix something when they're ready to do
it it sounds like Occupy Wall Street you
know and I think the reason critically I
also Wall Street had a lot of positive
stuff with it between before it went off
the tracks listen you can't have a
systems
yes
the good parts is you can't have this
concentration listen Obama remember
Obama ran as a anti-war populace to
defeat Hillary Clinton right something
Bernie Sanders didn't do in Two Shots on
goal okay he ran anti-war populace when
he came in with he inherited this
financial collapse and quite frankly did
the neoliberal way to just flood the
Zone take the federal reserve's balance
sheet put four trillion dollars on it
flood the zone to boost up uh assets of
real estate in in stocks and bonds go to
negative interest rates so the little
guy gets screwed they debated it the the
minutes of the president of the
governors of the of the Federal Reserve
dick Fisher down in Dallas he walked
through how you are doing this bailout
on the backs of working class and middle
class people who have no chance for
Capital formation their savings accounts
their checkings accounts their money
market accounts are going to have
nothing and 10 years from now they're
literally going to have nothing except
what they work for which were taxing at
essentially a 40 rate they're going to
have nothing until we vote on the
Silicon Valley Bank
next week or do you think it'll be two
weeks
I
was sure that they can do something like
that I mean they got you know it's like
you said well you have the tools or
we're going to admire them we're going
to use them I don't think they can do I
don't think they can get bail out well I
tell you how Edition predicts it on
no vote on the Silicon no no no but tell
them
however by the way you said did they
tell them how they're going to do it
they're going to use National Security
and they're going to use the Deep State
as the excuse that that Gates nailed
today early in our show they're going to
say that this is the centerpiece of all
these companies that are high-tech
companies in Silicon Valley all these
companies that let us compete with the
Chinese and if you don't let them make
payroll next week okay it's going to
collapse and we're going to be a decade
behind the CCP and they're going to make
it and make it announced so what's the
Coalition of votes there the Silicon
Valley Democrats led by rokana the
neoconservatives led by the traditional
voices of that movement in in the house
Republican caucus and then the
appropriators because they always you
know they spending money is not
typically something it's in the front to
someone on the Appropriations Committee
is that is that the the co that's the
Coalition that looks like 400 that looks
like 400 votes a lot more
a lot more Syrian
I don't see that Coalition coming
together I don't see Roca Hana as much
as he talks about economic patriotism
putting that Coalition together to have
a bailout of of East Palestine Ohio see
we're gonna you guys are going to replay
2008 and 2009 where Louis garment you
had you had a decision do we step in and
have intervention and try to save this
corrupt system by infusing it with
taxpayer cash to bail out the elites or
do we let the contagion spread and let
the devil catch the hindmost and the
problem is when you're looking into the
abyss it's a very tough call for you
guys to make because they're going to
sit there and go right now we're looking
into an open pit you have no idea how
deep this could go you know how the
American Financial system could collapse
how the International Financial system
collapse so you better vote to bail it
out with taxpayer cash so you're going
to take it from people making forty five
thousand dollars a year to bail out the
wealthiest people on Earth and they're
going to put a gun to your head and
they're going to say okay you're gonna
you you if you don't if you vote no and
let capital take its take it take its
path this contagion will spread they're
already talking about is it a contagion
or chemotherapy that's what I'm trying
to say yes are you saying let svb fail
I think you have to by the way until you
get a bailout of East Palestine Ohio
screw screw look those people are the
guys that mock and ridicule Maga every
day of the week this is the elite that
is it's an elite Bank the mo I think
most elite Bank in the country it only
has a certain clientele of the only the
best of these high-tech companies only
it's all the Venture capitalists it's
politically they all hate us and they
they Mock and ridicule the central part
of this country the the the coastal
Elites let their venture capital from
they got plenty of cash plenty of
capital let them go bail themselves out
physician heal thyself do not come to us
when you have not you sit there and you
Mock and ridicule East Palestine you
have some bogus uh
um a hearing when nothing gets settled
nothing gets sorted until East Palestine
gets a bailout there shouldn't be one
freaking penny I'm given to anything in
Silicon Valley I agree and it feels
similar to the energy I felt when when
you guys it up in the speaker's vote Yes
someone finally saying to the machine
you can't just steamroll us over and
over and over again this is the same
Play It's 2008 nine it's it's the it's
what the it is exactly exactly exactly
what's going to happen I don't know that
to what extent if you go back to town
halls if you go back to town halls in
your District next week next weekend
we'll say they've come to us with svb
and we're going to lose here's we're
going to lose the contagion is going to
spread to other Banks number two we're
going to lose all these great companies
uh and we're going to be lose all our
Innovation for a decade that's what
we're saying we're going to lose all
Innovation for a decade what is your
what is your District going to tell you
if a an earthquake hit Silicon Valley
I'm not sure that my constituents would
vote to send FEMA so with the banks
failing they certainly won't be won't be
in favor of sending their money he's the
master wow that's so great I I am uh
the part of me fears the ripple effect
on regular people part of me feels like
rip the Band-Aid off you cannot have
this moral hazard you simply cannot and
you know what Bannon told you moments
ago regular people are going to get
pinched in this fourth turning of we are
in we have to come out of it resilient
and strong as a country and and there
will be some good people uh who I think
will will pay the price but we cannot
allow this moral hazard to exist where
these companies can go focus on their
Dei and their ESG and they they can
induct the new era of cancer culture
through the financials it's going to be
very interesting to be a fly on the wall
at your conference because they're going
to come and make a presentation to the
conference they're going to show and
they're going to show they're going to
show the contagion spreading and they're
going to sit there go guys I know you're
not going to like it but we got to
saddle up and we don't everybody's got
to vote for it because you don't you're
going to make everybody else look bad
this is the pressure you're going to get
I think Andrew Yang called for it didn't
he I'm pretty sure he tweeted the
federal government should
backs.ubman already did Bill ackman's
Bill the hedge fund Bill agman already
said if there's not a deal with another
bank over the weekend we have to begin
the process of a federal bailout
immediately yeah Andrew yangs tweeted in
the absence of some kind of action
you'll see thousands of mass layoffs and
defunct companies a wiped out generation
of startups each problem in California
in particular and spreading Financial
contagion that will infect a host of
regional banks at a minimum
Monday everything on
and they're going to be calling you guys
back
because of the coven policies I don't
think people connect that there was this
belief that because of covid we were all
going to live in our pods eat the bugs
and you know have doordash delivered
their food read it again from the top
that's exactly this is summer Yang
summary I said perfectly in the absence
of some kind of action you'll see
thousands of mass layoffs and defunct
companies a wiped out generation of
startups huge problems in California in
particular and a spreading Financial
contagion that will infect a host of
regional banks at minimum I'd just like
to add the the you know he says that and
I'm sort of feeling worried until he
says huge problems in California in
particular and I'm like oh I'm not much
right there all that much
I'm just not I don't know how it goes
all the folks down in North Carolina
we've got to save California
a generation a generation a generation
of tech companies contagion spread it's
all the The Narrative those are the
those are the building blocks of the
narrative and they're going to work it
all weekend the Sunday shows are going
to all be about this it's not not going
to be about the financial policies of
Joe Biden and Powell and these radicals
and incompetence that cause the collapse
of of Silicon Valley Bank because that's
what caused it there'll be nothing about
that it'll all be about how we have to
step in and bail this thing out just go
your constituents and say please think
of the people in the Bay Area and how
much of your support they need there's
two Starbucks across street from each
other what if one of them goes under
they need to be saying because this is
what we've been waiting for that's right
yeah let Starbucks unionize first and
then we'll talk about it yeah that's an
interesting thing man what one I got
really triggered once because I saw a
meme that accused you of being a white
supremacist Steve
and uh and I see all these occupy people
insulting you and it's this picture of
you and they're just like it's a meme
where they they claim that you think
you're the master race and I'm like have
they listened to a single word Steven
has ever said because you you're the guy
who would be up on top of the stage
everything you just said yeah
bullhorning to all of these people this
is it and they'd be cheering for you but
the media introduces critical race
theory gender ideology lies about you
yeah and it splits up the people who
should be yeah agrees about money this
is this is the the collapse of the
neoliberal order is uh is a chance I do
royce royce White's uh show later the
collapse of the neoliberal order which
is predicated upon the slave labor of
China the Lao Beijing gives us an
opportunity to throw off the chains of
working-class people everywhere right
regardless of race or or gender or
um or uh religion right
um and we have a unique opportunity to
do that in this and uh and that's going
to come that's why populism's On The
Rise and particularly that's why I write
Wing what I'm proud to be a right-wing
populist that's why right-wing populism
is on the rise
so uh Min Liang tan co-founder and CEO
of Razer tweeted I think Twitter should
buy svb and become a digital Bank Elon
Musk replied I'm open to the idea
seems a bit silly I don't know how would
you what would you think about that if I
mean I think until Elon Musk starts
letting back on the most uh the true
anti-ccp people that he keeps blocked
off there myself include not that I want
to go on there oh yeah no no he's owned
but he's owned by the Chinese Communist
party what are you talking about Tesla
his only sense of only thing of real
value is Tesla he uses it for margin
loans he sells the stock the Shanghai
joint venture is a hundred percent
controlled by the CCP this is why this
is why he never goes after the CCP this
is why he always backs off this is when
they had the protest they had the
protests about the lockdowns of covet he
what he will not do it Elon Musk is a
total and complete phony he is in bed in
a business partner he's done some good
stuff of letting stuff out uh you know
with taibi and others it's fine but he
is owned Lock Stock and Barrel by the
Chinese Communist party and he acts like
it there was a story recently that they
warned him to stop talking about lab
leak 100 he's got and he I think there
was they wanted him to take down the
tweets he did the first time now he
didn't take him down but you notice he
didn't have any more up there after that
and I wonder if he said okay I won't
tweet more about it but here's the issue
I see with the CCP in the United States
and if the United States falters if this
fourth by the CCP Chinese companies are
on in this the Silicon Valley oh yeah
there's another thing they're already
talking about we think maybe up to a
third of those those Innovative
companies maybe CCP the principle that
we see in American politics applies
similarly to the rest of the world China
will crush you with a boot if you're if
you're operating within their borders
the United States will have committee
hearings they may find you they'll come
after you in the United States antifa
will throw a mortar through your window
and they'll Fire Bomb your house and the
right will struggle to say mean words
about you Matt Walsh calls an individual
unearthly and there's this oh I can't
believe he dared say that and then
antifa ransacks a government facilian
burns houses down and it's not even in
the news so I think I can see what's
going to happen if that pressure
continues Elon Musk is going to say look
I can go to the U.S I can rag on their
government I can rag on the problems
politically and it's fine in fact gets
me more supporters China will destroy me
in two seconds if I go anywhere near
that so I better shut up about them
see that's what I think with the FBI and
all this about the domestic terrorism
and the white supremacy all that I don't
think you can get there even in hearings
or whatever until you get to the bottom
of j6 I think j6 is so emblazoned in
people's memories if you go back and j6
change the way the FBI thought about
domestic violence extremism I mean we we
have been in depositions where the whole
construct of categorizing domestic
violence extremism the way they would
Mark a case you know for example if you
were investigating an organization you
would open a file uh and then you would
open up targets underneath that file
after j6 there was such a desire to
Resource an effort to combat domestic
violence extremism that they would say
in an organization if there were eight
people each separate person had to have
a separate file opened on them so that
they could create the veneer or the
illusion that there was a greater
problem than there ever was throughout
the country so they'd sign them assign
these cases to the individual field
offices instead of all of them being
washed and field office cases in order
to give the appearance of this
burgeoning spread of domestic violent
extremism you know but Matt on the other
hand
ever since I walked in the door up here
I've been hearing from these people to
sit down in hearings and Homeland
Security or Judiciary committees and
they'd tell us about the you know the
the most lethal threat to the Homeland
is domestic violent extremism so they
used January 6 to advance a narrative
you know I think it's sort of a way
station that Steve I think Tim is right
that you may be right the country don't
even go back and rehearse all the
Portland and Seattle and Chas and so
forth but the Atlanta attack does open
up a new chapter yes all of this is
weaponization actually you can see
there's another one the the the you
mentioned Whitmer you know one of the
FBI handlers in one with one of those
with the the Whitmer informant main doc
main guy there was trying to also run a
separate scan with respect to Ralph
Northam and there's that there's that
line that he uses the the FBI Handler to
the uh the confidential human Source who
is about to reach out to somebody's
trying to draw into one of these FBI
plots and he says and and the informant
ask for guidance and he says the plot is
specifically to kill the governor the
one the FBI is trying to inspire and
concoct yes plus there was another one
involving a BLM guy though that they
wanted to propose an assassination plot
against the Attorney General of Colorado
that it's what is up well let's let's
pause there because it's a tactical
decision we have to make uh you know
there have been circumstances where the
FBI has taken action against the left
that might offend our sense of civil
liberties and Dan and I believe that our
committee work will be more successful
if you get the few civil Libertarians
that still might exist as an endangered
species on the left interested in
somebody 100 I agree with you 100 I
think you ought to do the investigation
they try to do this left-wing groups you
got to expose that because ultimately it
can be turned against anybody it's the
apparatus that's the problem right so I
think I think if you can Garner support
report from the few remaining true civil
Libertarians are up there you definitely
don't do that and you ought to look at
what the abuses they did to left-wing
groups I'm sure they're out there they
are right well on advisor on fisa for
example Zoe Lofgren of California is an
ally to try to curtail the authorities
that have been abused you know how do we
put together ideas legislation that can
draw those people into a reform movement
yeah I I feel like you've mostly won the
civil Libertarians I I I find myself
sitting down with conservatives all the
time who have staunchly conservative
views that I mostly don't share but we
never even talk about that because the
issue is typically the weaponization of
governments the failure of our or
capture of our institutions so you end
up with this I call it sometimes the
freedom faction I guess because I'm like
saying the right doesn't make sense
because there are people who are
actually somewhat socialist lean I mean
Joe Rogan for instance talks about Ubi
and other socialist like policies he's
very left study would have voted for
Bernie and right he had been in the
general and then on all these issues
though he's not like well I'd rather
vote for Trump than Biden like okay well
how do you get a left-wing guy who likes
Bernie to say I'd rather vote for Trump
it's because the issue is facts if you
can sit down with someone who says
they're pro-life and want a flat tax or
something and then I say okay well we
can talk about that I guess but then
they're like oh and here's a book of
facts of what really happened and then
I'm like those are all true I agree with
you on that then you got another faction
of people that either don't know don't
care or believe lies
I I see
I think a lot of people who follow this
show for instance we've done a few polls
some informal some more formal and it's
like 40 moderates they don't consider
themselves conservatives or republican
they consider themselves like I used to
be a liberal I guess now I don't know
what's going on so I do feel like that
Coalition is here the question is
is it that people are too scared to get
active and speak out because
institutional capture well how many how
many people look you used to have a wide
swath of the of the center left
Democrats were civil Libertarians that's
an endangered species now you only have
you only have a very small hand but but
that will go against the narrative
because they're like stalinists on the
left down is that an interesting case
study is former Congressman current
Colorado governor Jared Polis Jared
Polis and Justin Amash were in a liberty
caucus together where they would fight
against government surveillance where
they would fight against endless Wars
and then Jared poliskos gets a little
power in the executive branch in
Colorado and and turns into a big
government command and Control Pro
lockdown Marxist left-wing fascist yeah
and it's it's crazy to see that
Evolution just with the introduction of
a little bit of Power with some of these
folks I want to try and read some super
chats I can't read them all because of
uh the way we have it set up but there
are some that I think are interesting
I'll try and read as many as I can this
one's actually interesting Christopher
Macy says I will worked for Silicon
Valley Bank left over a year ago they
were violating equal employment
opportunity laws consistently it was so
woke I had to leave Tim I sent an email
on what I'm doing to change culture and
feed my community and others appreciate
it so um the one thing I think uh could
be uh one approach is
we saw a young kid do that town hall on
CNN where he mentioned when it came to
critical race theory in schools it's
because these these lessons actually
violate the Civil Rights Act they
promote discrimination I'm wondering if
there's an approach going along with
what Mary Rose I'm sorry not Mary Rose
this was uh critical race Theory
explicitly a critique of the Civil
Rights Movement right is there is there
an approach in terms of institutional
capture that is hey this wokeness and
gender ideology is actually in violation
of the law and we can find a way to stop
it a number of folks have suggested that
that and and I think there's some
lossage to that effect that are rolling
around out there the problem is you're
going to have a difficult time defining
a suspect class
if you're making it some sort of equal
protection claim well I mean it's hard
to uh it's hard to say uh you take the
Title VII an employment uh
non-discrimination it's hard hard to say
that you're going to put people in a
room and and tell them that uh white
people are inherently bad and and uh and
and and make that not a violation of
Title VII which says you can't
discriminate or have a hostile work
environment based on race I mean it's
the epitome of a hostile work
environment so I don't think it's I
don't think there's a difficulty
defining a suspect class there I think
that statute is pretty straightforward
it's amazing I think the same thing is
true in Title Nine time yeah the
education title and so forth Paul
Engelbrecht says we need olive branches
passed between the Tea Party and Occupy
Wall Street activists they were fighting
for the same thing with different views
of who and how to of of how and who to
fight I actually disagree I think um in
the early days of occupy it was
identical to everything that Steve was
just saying and the issue was awokeness
started to creep in from trust fund kids
who lived in Brooklyn and didn't
actually stay at the park Libertarians
and conservatives started to leave
because they were like what is this I
don't want to be involved in this but
the general message from for the most
part was populist they were upset about
the best I agree with him though that's
what I think the Olive Branch I think
there's many things that the left-wing
populace and the right-wing populists
can agree on particularly about
economics you're completely right and
foreign
the neoliberal neocon order is
collapsing we've got to come up with a
alternative I have a friend who uh we're
actually currently working with who I
met during Occupy Wall Street he's still
very much like an anti-federal Reserve
guy he's like we got to audit the FED we
got to get to the bottom of how they use
Finance to manipulate and control the
people and Destroy lives and and
pressure the society and then when you
when you look at his posts on Facebook
the people who used to agree 100 with
everything he's saying are now posting
things about wokeness and when he tries
to talk to him say guys I understand
you're upset about this but this Finance
stuff they're doing and they're like
it's it's white supremacy you're wrong
and it feels like those activists are
gone they've they've for whatever reason
been pulled into a totally different
headspace yeah call it an effective
psyup I guess
I don't see that many I I agree with you
I think that's that's what I encounter I
don't know where you know Matt is one of
the one he's probably the most
um knowledgeable Republican in the
conference about where the people would
be on the Democrat side who might join
in that kind of thing and how many man
how many I don't know you know
unfortunately the Democrats are better
at the kind of shirts versus skins
politics in in Washington and I don't
think it's more than a small handful
anymore and it's actually diminishing
it's a it's a diminishing brand among
Democrats to believe in robust speech I
mean the only Democrat who spoke out
about the horrors of the Twitter files
was the much mentioned on this episode
I typically when uh people ask me if
there's any good Democrats I'm like well
Khan has done some good things I don't
know enough about him to say that we
made a movie together people should go
watch the swamp on HBO I get a movie
with uh rokana Thomas Massey and Ken
Buck HBO followed us around for entire
year as we as we try to build those
bridges with the populist right I think
I think Roe Kahana is very shortly is
going to become a very viable potential
presidential candidate by the way that's
why I think he didn't run for the Senate
yeah I believe that Roe Connor would
have beat Adam Schiff and Katie Porter
in first Senate race but right now the
House of Representatives actually gives
you a more mutualist
and modern and modern media culture you
want to be in the house you think he's
going to run this this the cycle well
not with Biden but I think that he's
he's Biden's going to be the Democratic
nominee I do not think I do not think
he's gonna be the Democratic number no
Marion Williamson she's running don't
don't play her
I think she brings a whole different
element I agree and I'm deeply offended
at how they treat her it's it's shock
dismissive probably Robert F Kennedy
Bobby Kennedy's going to run did you did
you should run as a republican but he's
going to run on the anti-vaxx platformer
he'll get he'll get 10 of primary votes
still turn out I'm not so sure on a
Democratic primary but he
by the way just he took Trump's economic
nationalism and just turns it into
economic patriotism when he goes
throughout the Midwest and he's
obviously very very knowledgeable I
think he's I think he could be a very
formidable candidate in the future do
you see what they what crane John Pierre
said about Marianne Williamson I mean it
was actually kind of embarrassing what
she did she was asked about Marion
Williams announcing she wanted to run
against Biden and she struggled to say
crystal ball instead if I had a what did
you call it an orb if she or some a
globe and she said if I had a globe or
uh
exactly the right word but this is this
is the thing what the Zen master
Jean-Pierre I think that what the media
did to Marion Williamson is it shows one
of the reasons why they hated Trump so
much they made something up about her
and made it stick she's not a crystal
lady that she she's even been like why
are they saying this about me it was
actually kind of upsetting when I'm
watching this she's like I've never
owned a crystal why are they calling me
this and I'm like what's welcome to the
media if people believe in the FED I've
got no problem with people believing in
the crystals well they're doing it to
make her seem like she's a hippie weirdo
who has no idea what's going on so
here's what I where I agree with Marion
Williamson the most health care policy
it seems as though whenever lawmakers
debate Health Care policy all we're
really talking about is who's going to
pay for the health care yeah we don't
ever really have a health care policy to
make people healthier right and it
sickens me that we continue to subsidize
these very unhealthy food foods for poor
people than those poor people find
themselves in bad health and then we
subsidize the bad health and the
disability the SSID on the back end and
it is a function of what I believe is a
corrupt system in Washington DC largely
run by lobbyists and and interest groups
I want to I want to read this from
steadily he said svb CEO sold 3.5
million dollars in shares two weeks
before the collapse yes
by the way the CFO threw in another 750.
Patrick McHenry this has got to be your
net your witness next week financial
services
before they come for a bailout before
they come from bailout you ought to have
the CEO and the CFO in front of with
McHenry in in a finance committee
getting grilled right there why did you
dump work of the financial services
committee would come before this like
what do you have the nerve to schedule
before questions for that guy check this
out uh Matthew M says Etsy sellers
didn't get paid today it's not just the
woke Bank as much as I understand not
wanting to bail out bankers
so who didn't get paid Etsy Etsy sellers
yes no this is this is already you know
Wells Fargo had some problems there's
some problems in other places Wells
Fargo said was a computer glitch this is
First Republic Bank where does you know
all about all over the mainstream media
we see the this is the contagion
contagion is like the word of of the
week coming up okay where does it go
Silicon Valley Bank had uh 17 billion
dollars of uh unrealized losses in its
security and it's in its government
securities portfolio because they bought
governments and the bonds are getting
crushed because of Biden's economic
policies
on other Banks I think the number the
Wall Street Journal said was 600 billion
dollars of losses right losses on other
Banks right now so this could this could
spread just because the bond market is
getting crushed okay this could spread
this contagious could spread because
what Biden has done to bury this country
in this continual over-the-top spending
with the collaboration as Mitch
McConnell and these guys in the Senate
uh that has driven the FED now to Jack
Rachel Kramer say at the end of the day
uh he's he's taking rates up too much
he's bringing down the system around him
he's got to stop the rate increases so
because that's that kills these bonds so
you're going to see over the weekend
none of these banks are going to be
sleeping they're all going to be going
through their portfolios they're all
going to be ready to say how they're
going to trade on Monday we're in a
crisis this is this is not a solo thing
I happen to think it's systemic it's
maybe it's just One Bad Apple I don't
believe that and and people should be on
top of this and you guys should be
calling emergency hearings and get guys
in here the Federal Reserve the bank
Regulators first question why do the
California's fed policy that's because
there are multiple tools that's what he
was saying you don't need to maybe come
to you guys hey because you'll just go
to an existing event yes exactly wow
that would they're they're the first
question I would ask is why did the
California Regulators seize the bank
hours before the FED why was Janet
Yellen that the control of the currency
the Federal Reserve why was the Biden
regime not on top of this why did they
let this thing Fester when Peter when
Peter teal sits there the other day goes
take Peter teal is a very conservative
guy and he doesn't have his hair on fire
when he comes out and says take your
money out of the bank that's a papal
bull okay so this is
and why did Yellen not move why did the
Biden regime not move because they don't
want to they don't want to show the
nation it's their economic policies that
brought us to our knees okay and that's
what you're going to find out and the
question is is this now what's happening
in the bond market because the bond
market is 20 times bigger than the stock
market is it actually really going to
end up crushing the American Financial
system I got to tell you it's we're
going to be in scary times this is like
2008 remember this is the second biggest
bank failure in the history of the
country wow the second biggest bank
value had 208 billion dollars of assets
this is the only bigger one happened
during the financial crisis of 2008 this
is the 16th largest bank in the country
and this is this is not a small thing
this is going to hit crypto as well
because uh Silver Lake early in the week
how much of this is one of the coins
that's being used is is uh got 25 of its
Holdings in svb so now people are
consider is going to definitely get take
another hit a Bitcoin was under 20 000 a
day so oh boy so how much of this is
these crazy valuations that a lot of
these tech companies have gotten as a
result of the Bible a lot a lot a lot of
it the easy money in in they raise a ton
of money and they put this money in this
bank and now they can't get to it so
it's a necessary corrective right well
okay so this is the question you guys
are going to end this is 2008. to uh
you're looking into the abyss you don't
know how it's going to be do you vote
trillions of dollars for bailouts and
the bailouts are all on the back of
shareholders excuse me of taxpayers
making 40 000 bucks a year okay and the
elite are going to make out so so you so
you've socialized you've mitigated their
downside right you you've socialized
their losses and you let them have
upside they have unlimited upside but
they have limited downside because this
because the the taxpayers are going to
bail it out and that's the question
that's going to come back to this
Congress and this is the big fight we
had in 2009 and people kind of said okay
okay okay and we ended up doing it and
we never got to the problem we have
still so many zombie Financial companies
the too big to fail uh situation with
the banks and the financial system we
never got to the bottom of it we never
Lance the boil let the pus come out
because guess what that's a brutal tough
process if the ruling class does that
again the people are coming with
pitchforks that's that's it
by the way the first line of defense is
you guys because the big debates are
going to remember they it's a certain
basketball Schumer passed this to put
pressure on the house you think I think
it's going to be big remember in 2008
let's just go back when Lehman collapsed
because they got tired of moral hazard
uh what they've done the thing about is
that the commercial paper Market which
is the way all the companies overnight
get their cash in the cafeterias and to
pay everybody it was the center the
commercial paper Market collapsed so the
whole system froze by Thursday they went
to see Bush and they said this is uh
Paulson in Bernanke and he said we need
a trillion dollars by five o'clock or
the American Financial system will
collapse in 48 hours and the world
financial system will collapse in 72
hours you have Global Anarchy something
the Nazis couldn't do the the military
Junta in Japan couldn't do our greatest
enemies couldn't do this to us we did it
to ourselves and Bush said I don't have
the authority to do that you have to go
up to the house the only person has the
ability to do that is the speaker of the
house and the house has to vote this
right they're the only people that can
actually commit money and so that's what
this whole process started and that's
where all those huge debates on the
floor with Louis Gomer and and five
Libertarians sitting there going no it's
called capitalism let it rip right and
they were overwhelmingly everybody said
okay that's great theoretically we can't
do that because and there may not be a
bottom of this thing you guys are gonna
be faced with the same thing over the
next couple weeks and local governments
and state governments who are heavily
utilizing the bond market will be the
right behind the Neo robini said we have
because of the zero interest rates we
went to right now in the world there's
300 trillion dollars of debt that debt
at the personal level at the county
level the school board level the Border
level the the local government city
state federal government of everywhere
it's 300 trillion dollars all basically
predicated on an interest rate structure
that's close to zero now that interest
rate structure is at four percent for 10
year the 10-year bond and five percent
for two remember the night the election
was stolen from Donald Trump on on the
evening of three November 2020. enjoy
being on YouTube yeah well Steve
bannon's completely wrong about it on
three November 2020 when fox called
Arizona for for Joe Biden the 10-year
treasury was 0.86 the 10-year treasury
days four percent right that's a massive
increase and by the way people under 30
the millennial generation has nine
trillion dollars of debt you guys are
not what I've said for years are nothing
but Russian surfs you're adding debt at
a faster Pace than any other generation
our history and you're not going to be
able to pay you're like a hamster on a
wheel but with a little bit of credit so
this is only going to get this is only
going to get worse dramatically worse so
what does that mean for us other than I
mean the economy gets bad
yeah the economy we can expect but then
he started having bankruptcies what
you're going to start to have is not the
inability to pay well right now the debt
ceiling yeah we're essentially a
bankrupt Nation okay we have this thing
called the Federal Reserve that
continues to print money and it can
continue to print money because the the
biggest export we have in the world is
the dollar every transaction and this is
why what the CCP announced today with
Iran and Saudi Arabia so big because
they're doing 40-year output as as the
Green New Deal comes here and we're
trying to get to a net carbon zero that
Saudi Arabia and Iran are getting more
important to China the CCP who just burn
anything and they're doing long-term
output deals for all their production
40-year deals and they're going to use
the you want the Chinese currency and
take it directly and bear the risk that
that comes not converted into Petro
dollars once we are not the reserve
currency which Great Britain was up
until World War II we took over at
Bretton Woods after the war because we
were the superpower once that is not our
top export once every whether it's a
drug deal are converting something to
put into a church in France in the in
the uh in the collection plate once it
does we're not the prime Reserve
currency we're Argentina thank the
cartels still operate in the U.S dollar
exactly
moving to the one I mean we really need
the car so so where this is headed right
now their debate this their debate look
Biden just put in your face a 6.8
trillion dollar budget that has no Cuts
anywhere basically six percent growth
not one cut and so he's not prepared to
meet anybody halfway and you have a debt
ceiling right now that we see from the
Congressional budget office at minimum
will add 19 trillion dollars in 10 years
that means we'll have 50 trillion
dollars of debt you understand we're
going to have growth it's going to kill
growth under two percent you're going to
have lost a Lost Generation or two in
this country with under two percent
growth overbearing debt so much money go
to pay off the debt no opportunity no
Venture Capital no ability to grow the
economy everybody
uh living like a Russian surf that is
thank goodness the Zoomers are mentally
healthy enough for this no but hold on
the resiliency they've shed Frailty but
that's that's what I'm thinking about
I'm not painting such a Rosy picture
Steve I'm not sure I uh I'm I'm all that
worried if that's the worst case
scenario I think one thing my generation
and the younger generation need is to
learn how to roll up their sleeves chop
some wood and raise some chickens one of
the problems that we've had with
Millennials and gen Z is they've they've
been born into a world with with silver
spoons up their asses everything you I
mean they they want for nothing you uh
the story I tell is the first day I walk
in device media with my job I was
shocked to find that people didn't even
show up and were getting 30 to 60k
depending on what your writing job was
and people don't show up here and they
get 172 000 well absolutely but I'm in
New York City and I'm thinking to myself
some of these people are getting 50 some
of these people are getting 100K and
they don't even show up and I come from
a world where I was loading bags in
airplanes for 10 bucks an hour and
people are getting injured they're
getting they're getting uh repetition
injuries if I said if the people the
working class of this country found out
what life was like for the for the
laptop class they'd be a revolution
overnight the idea that someone's
getting 40 50 bucks an hour to think
about how they can write another article
about how racist Trump is and meanwhile
some other person is breaking their back
lifting steel beams for 20 30 bucks an
hour they're going to be are you kidding
me that this this can't be that way so
this generation they need to learn where
to chop some wood where these guys are
going to come into the pressure not just
the bailout of of sbv and stop and think
contagion but then you get right into
the spending into the debt ceiling and
you're you're going to get
um the emotions of this are going to be
huge because they're saying you're going
to throw kids well that's right you're
going to get this is going to be the
battle of the ages on Finance in this
country that what happens right now the
debt ceiling give me Etc well no you
gotta draw the line if you give them an
inch and I mean an inch because right
now you you don't have to uh you don't
have have to do anything to any
government security you've got enough
cash coming in to pay the interest and
pay the face amount of the debt you'll
never default a default has to be done
by the Secretary of Treasury but these
guys are going to be guilt-tripped every
day the media is going to be it's going
to be a government shutdown to the 100th
power I gotta ask you I mean this story
is really breaking on a Friday right yes
this that says to me they knew it was
coming well in advance and it was
planned for this day because this is the
day where everyone's off partying and
not paying attention that's Friday's
where news goes to die so it sounds like
they knew this was coming and they
wanted to well they definitely didn't
know they definitely yeah
the the the California Regulators for a
bank or a state regulator step in front
of the fed and something like this and
federal authorities is unheard of on a
bank that's not some local Community
Bank so what's the news on pivot
in real trouble on this because I think
Newsom this is going to hit this thing
but I think Newsom is going to step in
and start to he's going to come back and
make the big play that you got to bail
this out this is the future he comes to
Washington 100. Gavin knew someone would
come and say this California model is
actually the model for the country it's
high tech we're the leader in the world
if you don't do this we're going to be a
decade behind the CCP these are the
Thousand the best California is a donor
state if you have donor State on your
bingo card this will be this will be his
pretty powerful counter argument
everything turns to where the
Santas went to Iowa Newsom will come to
Washington DC to make his case as a
national figure that he's there to save
the high-tech economy and you got to do
it and by doing a bailout and these
liberals will just March in lockstep
they'll repeat whatever they hear on the
TV what did yanger say that's exactly
that's already that's already The
Narrative they got it on Friday hey
they're not taking Friday night off
they're hammering this non-stop when I
left they're hammering and they're not
nobody's talking about how did this
happen how did we actually get here
right how did we actually get here so I
want to ask you Steve so you just said a
minute ago or a few minutes ago that the
world's 300 trillion you don't need to
get too close it's very sensitive yeah
who are we in debt to
well first off we're in debt to the
Chinese that own a first of all we have
32 trillion on on the balance sheet of
the treasure we have another nine
trillion at the at the FED that Japanese
insurance companies own it the um the um
uh the Chinese Own It insurance
companies here own it but we own a lot
of it a lot of it's just created we make
up these bonds right that we in fact
that we in fact own we've we've kind of
paid for so a big part of this is the
public owning its own debt right so we
own it to ourselves now to the rest of
the world they owe it to everybody they
don't have the luxury of just creating a
self the reason one of the reasons we
have the luxury we are the prime Reserve
currency we export dollars and
everybody's got to do every transaction
in the world because of that but it's
going to be but do you think when you
talk about the dollar uh under attack
from this Alliance don't you think that
the sanctions regime that our country
has embraced over time has gas lit that
like it has it seems because the switch
system the Swiss system be able to do
sanctions and then cut them off the
Swift system which is the way you do
transactions is is is
exacerbated sections seem to always get
a lot of bipartisan support in
Washington but if sanctions worked
Cuba would be a Caribbean Paradise not a
country and if sanction
sanctions worked you know we would see
Venezuela develop as the jewel of South
America the reality is sanctions tend to
hurt the people that live in these
countries I haven't seen Maduro miss too
many meals as a country well I think I
think grabbing an empanada on TV is a
classic historical moment remember that
he's giving his National address and
then he just grabs an empanada out of a
drawer and then bites it and puts it
back that was basically Trump's moment
with the taco salad right yeah but he's
doing it while people are starving I
don't think it's not the best taco
salads follow question if we owe the
debt to ourselves why don't we just not
pay it you can't do that because it's
actual debt it's got an interest payment
it's it's up there you can't you can't
by the way by the way there is an aspect
there is there is a heart out there oh
there there is an aspect of doing that
and that is by the way they asked it the
other day I think Timmins of North
Carolina to come up with the the
trillion dollar the trillion dollar coin
yeah someone someone mentioned that
membership and by the way he asked the
question he asked the question of of uh
would uh Powell take it could you print
a coin and just call a trillion dollar
coin and use that to actually D level
the United States and he said hey that's
a gimmick just like getting off the
debts of gimmick I know you got to go
writing off the interest though I mean
if the interest is owed to a fraudulent
system like a Swiss bank bank for
international settlements why are we as
Americans adherent why do you say why do
you say that it's a illegitimate system
look it's a Ponzi scheme
it's it's basically to give us money and
then they demand interest back on the
money they gave us but we in order to
get the interest to pay it back we have
to borrow it from them
okay default
I don't know but like people should know
how to do some hard work or something
Americans though right 24 TR I think 24
trillion is owed to Americans and by the
way that's the of the next 16 we'll sell
a couple of trade into the Chinese a
couple trillion to the to the Japanese
and we'll we'll owe it to ourselves so
you got a heart stop and we and we do
need to start winding it down I guess so
this has been absolutely awesome to sit
here with you guys how did you the
question how do you broadcast
from the capitol you're on YouTube
you're in the capital I come here I come
here my file's been taken because I got
four months in the federal prison coming
up uh but my father my file's been sent
to the Bureau of Prisons already
what do I have to do to get on war room
the first time we come down here but
you're a hero we love to book you the
first time we come half the channels on
our mixer aren't working
and we don't know why we can't figure it
makes no sense because we do this all
the time we have the mobile setup so
we're like we're gonna we're gonna come
here we're gonna make sure it works
everything's working perfectly we sound
check everything sounds great then all
of a sudden a half an hour before the
show the board just stops working out
right it's producing sound the computer
won't take it and I'm like this makes no
sense so we do a we put one of the
headphone outs into our atem
everything's working perfectly then as
soon as we click live the audio just
drops to like half levels and we're like
War Room Capital yeah hey right before
War Room Prison Break hey I got a text
it's awesome to see you on Tim Poole's
show I'll watch him a lot cool man I
love it I appreciate it thank you so
much I gotta go do Royce White I don't
know absolutely another YouTube show
we're wrapping up but I will say I think
it would be awesome if uh I mean next
time they're they're there's big stuff
going on in Washington if we could do
more of this stuff no no no we got to
bring Gates and Congressman Bishop to
Harpers Ferry
I left breadcrumbs
wait till you see Congressman has to go
to Harvard okay my wife wants to go
skateboard there
oh yeah yeah we'll do a music video I
think it'd be fantastic we could have
you in the music video she can sing and
then we'll trigger the corporate liberal
press they'll be freaking out you ever
mixed the skateboarding in the music
videos
no I mean we could I'm just saying
gentlemen uh this has been absolutely
incredible I really do appreciate it uh
this has been fantastic we got to do it
again
um is there uh you guys can follow me uh
at timcast you can become a member at
timcast.com if you want us to do more of
this the way things have been going
economically I think we're we are only
surviving right now and I mean this
because of uh the membership system that
we have at timcast.com
ads will not support us so I mean there
was a period where ADS were doing really
well but right now for whatever it is
for whatever reason ads are not doing so
well but because you guys become members
at timcast.com I haven't really worried
about it so so long as you are You
Believe in Us and you keep supporting us
we'll keep doing more stuff like this do
you guys want to shout anything out I
got a podcast called Firebrand I hope
everybody subscribes and uh even got a
great episode with Dan Bishop in there
so right on absolutely you can't get
enough there's more out there for you
great to be with you Tim thank you so
much for for allowing us to come down to
the Capitol again and do this I mean
it's a tremendous opportunity for us uh
Matt I think the work you do is
absolutely fantastic both of you guys in
the fight for over the the speakership I
was we were all laughing we were
cheering when we were doing the show
because it really did it felt like
somebody was actually just standing up
for for someone so many Americans who
are tired of the machine so uh with that
being said thank you all so much for
everything and for everybody who's
watching thanks for the support and
we'll see